La emisión está comenzando. Todos los asistentes están en modo de solo escucha.
¿Qué tal? Muy buenas tardes. Saludo un martes más de la N clase del curso de
Trádigo en México. Me parece que es la 13, ¿verdad? Yo, como no soy supersticioso, pues es
la clase número 13. La clase número 13, una clase en la que imagino se nota un cambio de
voz. No es que esté dando el curso otra persona, sino que es que estoy en un resfriado de cierta
importancia. Y bueno, pues ahí estoy. Tengo la voz un poquito ronca. Confío en poder aguantar
toda la clase. Bueno, perfecto. Empezamos bien. Empezamos bien porque se ha colgado el
access layer. He reiniciado todo pensando, venga, así era todo mejor. Y no, no, a
mejor hubiera sido mejor no reiniciar porque estaba yendo todo muy bien. En fin, bueno,
ya lo sabes viendo, ya lo sabes viendo. Esto a veces pasa cuando abres multicharts. Pero no pasa
siempre. No pasa siempre. A ver si aguanta. No sé, de momento parece que funciona. Parece que
funciona. Me ha dicho que se colgaba, pero parece que funciona. No sé. Bueno, ahora lo sé. Espera,
espérate. Dale tiempo. Ya está, ya está. Ahí está. Venga, va a tomar el viento todo. Sí, sí,
lo sé, lo sé. Envíalo todo y déjame un rato. Venga. No, no, yo nuevamente hablo de 3.6 y luego
multicharts, pero no sé. Bueno, pues voy a... No, no, yo he estado todo el día trabajando con
todos los dos y sin ningún tipo de problema. Yo creo que es al estar emitiendo. La tarjeta
gráfica es más usada y bueno. Me he equivocado reiniciando porque estaba todo perfecto de la
forma y a lo mejor no hubiera habido problema, pero mira, pues he pensado que sería mejor y veo
que no, pero bueno. Bueno, mientras va arrancando voy explicando cositas que tengo que explicar,
pero esperaros que todavía no soy capaz de hacer 2, 3. Bueno, 2 ya estoy haciendo, pero 3, 4 ya me
cuesta más. Vamos con multicharts. Bien, empezamos como siempre dando un repasito breve al Discord.
Había alguna cosita que comentar. Bueno, Alejandro había añadido al hilo de... No sé si es que
Alejandro quizá no está siguiendo las casas. Creo que no está en directo usualmente que las
siga posteriori, pero no sé si lleva mucho retraso o qué, pero bueno. Poco insiste en lo mismo,
¿vale? Supongo que en algún momento lo escuchará Alejandro. Hoy vamos a ver un sistema tendencial
porque siempre, como os digo, el curso es un ente vivo que voy adaptándolo un poco a lo que veo,
a vosotros comentarios, a lo que creo también que es mejor para todos. Y hoy justamente vamos a ver
algún sistema de este estilo. Yo el otro día dije que eso es algo que pasa y que se soluciona
con diversificación. Es verdad que hay que intentar que no pase, eso es obvio, ¿de acuerdo? Es decir,
no quería decir que no hay que intentarlo, pero un tendencial puro contra más puro es más le pasa.
Y hoy veréis que al final, aunque es un sistema basado totalmente tendencial puro, al final el
sistema quiere salir, pero eso va a ser siempre así, quiere salir. Si le obligas a elegir una
salida, pues al final busca un TP, un stop, ¿de acuerdo? Porque, y aún así lo mantiene tendencial,
porque evidentemente el hecho de poner un TP no anula que sea tendencial, porque todo depende
del TP que ponga. Si pongo un TP que está a un 8%, seguramente va a ser tendencial porque va a saltar
solo en pocas veces y en ocasiones en que haga un run-up muy largo. Entonces al final todo depende
de la relación de uno con otro. Pero evidentemente un TP que son los que pueden tener este tipo de
curva que se ve ahí, que enseñaba Alejandro, pues puede pasar. Pero como bien él comenta,
nunca se sabe lo que va a pasar, entonces en tal tendencia, esto lo hemos vivido ahora mismo en
el oro. Como hoy vamos a ver un sistema en el oro, bueno, vamos a ver dos, pero vamos a trabajar uno
y vais a ver pues que esto pasa, esto pasa, ¿vale? Eso es algo que ocurre y
la inquietud dice, dice Alejandro, que si esto no, esto pasa no solo en este activo,
sino en otros muchos, porque, insisto, insisto Alejandro, que no sé si no lo has oído. La
mejor diversificación no es por activo, esto lo hemos hablado ya en la teoría, lo he dicho muchas
veces en la práctica, es por estrategia. Es mejor en el mismo activo tener estrategias muy distintas
que tener la misma estrategia en distintos activos, pero evidentemente combinar ambas cosas es lo ideal,
¿vale? Y pones el ejemplo del oro, efectivamente, se lidia, como dije, con diversificación, pero
diversificación, sobre todo por estrategia, ¿vale? Y luego Juan Manuel aquí al final apuntaba una
serie de comentarios en línea con nuestro comentario de decirle que nos dijerais aquellas cosas que nos
faltan o que creéis que pueden faltar, porque, como ya os comentamos, habíamos puesto de fecha
final al curso, ¿de acuerdo? Que no quiere decir que no pueda cambiar, pero vamos a intentar que no,
¿vale? Bien, Loel Bix, no sé si lo veremos como tal, comenta también un sistema del COD, si eso me
comprometo, aunque sea en la clase final, pensar que luego después de estas cuatro, Juan Manuel,
prácticamente seguro habrá otra que podemos ubicar alrededor de un mes o quizá mes y medio después,
por dar una fecha, ya la fijaremos, lógicamente, pero esa será posterior y para, pues, acabar que
todo el mundo vea el curso, incluso aquel que lo pueda volver a ver y entonces ahí sí que, pues,
este tipo de cosas que pueden quedar, pues, ya se pueden ahí repasar, ¿vale? Pero el COD sí que
entiendo que sí que en algún momento lo veré. Matriz de Excel con Moni-Manage-Media-Algorithmo,
esto va a la clase de porfolio, esto en principio tengo dos pensadas, probablemente serán no la
siguiente sino la otra y la otra, ¿vale? Es decir, 30 de abril y 7 de mayo, probablemente. Plan de
supervisión, ya hemos hablado y enseñamos el código y algo hemos visto en la práctica,
no tenía pensado ver mucha cosa más, pero sí que dijimos que os haríamos el código. Somos
conscientes que tenemos cosas pendientes de daros, eso sí que tranquilos, que de hecho hoy voy a
pronunciar que os voy a dar más, voy a tener que ir parando por la tos, eh, disculparme, pero es
lo que hay. Entonces sí que sí que intentaremos daros este código y somos conscientes de que
quedan algo, que tengo algunas cosas anotadas, pero no os las he dado, por ejemplo, porque en
el de salidas de la semana pasada quiero desarrollar un poco más las entradas, ¿vale? Para poneros
alguna entrada más y dejaros ahí una, un buscador de ideas, que es un poco lo que me comentas ahí,
un buscador de ideas, es eso, es eso. Juan Manuel, es decir, hoy vas a ver, por ejemplo,
un buscador de ideas aplicado al sistema tendencial, vale, que vamos a ver. Entonces,
crear un buscador de ideas, hay varias maneras, eh, hay varias maneras, también hay código,
pero es que como os dije Juan Manuel, en algún sitio tengo que parar, yo lo entiendo, o sea,
porque por ejemplo de Kauma tenemos también buscadores de ideas, pero en algún sitio hay que
parar, es decir, ya vamos a pasar de las 90 horas, creo, al final, entonces en algún sitio
hay que parar, entonces yo, yo, yo, porque por material de verdad, eh, no, no pararíamos nunca,
no pararíamos nunca, se podrían ir haciendo talleres, se podrían ir haciendo temáticas,
se podrían ir haciendo mil cosas. Más adelante, de aquí a un tiempo, pues ya valoraremos si alguien
quiere hacer cosas, talleres, no sé, ya veremos, pero ahora mismo no es tan mente, eh, como ya os
he comentado, o sea, esto al final, aquí tenemos unas entradas y unas salidas, estos no quiero
desarrollar más, vale, quiero poner más entradas para que ya tendáis esto de buscador de setups
entrada y todas las 32 salidas que hay, esto es un buscador de ideas, de acuerdo, esto tú lo puedes ir
aplicando a cualquier código, de hecho, esto hoy lo vamos a aplicar al sistema tendencial del oro,
vamos a usar este módulo para buscarle salidas, de acuerdo, entonces esto es un buscador de ideas,
que hay más, hay más cosas siempre, pero este es uno, uno de ellos, eh, hemos visto ya varias
maneras, os he hablado mucho de stock and commodities, os de, os di todo el código de stat, acordaros,
todo el código de stat y hoy ya os avanzo, pero no lo avanzo, lo diré después, porque quiero enseñaros
una cosa de él, aquí os he dado todo el código de stat, que es dos mil y pico páginas, o sea,
y ahí hay cosas aprovechables, eh, de verdad, y mucho contenido de, o sea, como idea, no, no,
no quedaros con, no quedaros igual que aquí en las clases, con todo un sistema cerrado, no,
es decir, se trata de trabajar las, las, las cosas, mezclarlas y ir aprendiendo, vale, entonces,
eh, ya digo, de, de ideas ahí tienes apatadas, apatadas, vale, y hoy vamos a ver algunas,
algunas más, eh, vale, aquí tengo, eh, bueno, tengo ya una pequeña versión del sistema LORON,
que no está aún filtrada, pero vamos a empezar por el principio, vamos a empezar por el principio,
para eso voy a intentar abrir 3stations, voy a intentar abrir 3stations, no te creo, bueno,
pues nada, no quiere hoy que habrá 3stations y multicharts, bueno, pues voy a empezar por
3stations, vuelvo a cerrar todo, increíble, eh, todo el día he estado con los 2 abiertos, todo el día,
que además el equipo no está saturado, es, es realmente, no lo está, no sé, no sé qué deciros,
no sé qué deciros, pero voy a abrir solo 3stations, sin multicharts y ahí, ahí veremos,
en fin, paciencia, áname, paciencia, áname, paciencia, pero ya, bien, aprovecho para comentar
que lo comenté en la ponencia Robotev y aquí lo he dejado caer, eh, alguna vez y, eh, sé que
alguno de vosotros ha enviado, eh, currículum, eh, va en serio lo del trabajo, eh, no os penséis que
era un brindis al sol, es lo que pasa que probablemente hasta que no acabe el curso no
tendré tiempo para abordarlo, ¿vale?, pero va totalmente en serio, así que aquel que, que lo aquella
que esté interesado, pues como ya habéis hecho algunos de ellos, ya os hemos respondido que,
que lo veremos en próximas semanas, pues, eh, que queréis presentar candidatura, eh, ya digo,
un alumno del curso es un perfecto candidato, eh, no penséis que por tener, o sea, porque estamos
abiertos tanto a perfiles junios como perfiles senios, lógicamente son perfiles distintos,
pero es posible o probable incluso que a lo largo del año tengamos que cubrir los dos, por lo tanto,
casi que me da igual cubrir primero uno que cubrir otro, explico, es decir, que podemos estar abiertos
ambos, ambos perfiles y alguien que ha hecho el curso que lo estaba o que lo está haciendo y tal,
pues es una persona perfectamente apta y válida para, para incorporarse y si es un junior seguir
aprendiendo ya con nosotros y si es un senior, pues, pues ya empezar a aportar ya antes, ¿no?,
a la compañía y ahora ¿qué pasa? De verdad, a que se me ha abierto aquí debajo de todo esto ahora.
Bien, ahora voy a abrir solo 3Session porque ahí sé que entiendo que no se va a colocar,
trabajaré un rato con 3Session y entonces cuando ya intente ir a multichars, pues veremos si puedo,
si no, pues me quedaré con 3Session, no quedará otra, otra posibilidad, lógicamente, así que vamos
a intentarlo porque no es normal, ya digo, tiene que ver algo con el hecho de estar con, no sé,
con la cámara, estoy pensando, no debería, la verdad, no sé, que no encuentro ninguna lógica.
Lo que sí que en línea con lo que os comentaba, preferiblemente por bastantes, es decir,
que no lo cierro a 100% porque depende, a lo mejor en un perfil senior muy específico,
todos podríamos a lo mejor aceptarlo, pero no en un junior, ya os lo digo, es decir,
es para trabajar presencialmente en Reus, así que aquel que viva lejos y no considere desplazarse,
pues ya no hace falta que postule porque eso es una condición para nosotros que aporta mucho valor
al equipo y por lo tanto es complicado que renunciemos a ella. Bueno, vamos allá, que ya parece que,
ah no, pero esto no es lo que yo tenía antes cargado, eh, este no es lo que yo tenía cargado,
tenía el otro gráfico al lado, Alberto, no entiendo nada, se va abriendo otro, se va abriendo otro,
estoy abriendo otro, no sé bien bien cuál de hecho, pero estoy abriendo otro, seguro,
porque es que lo he guardado 100%, ah, es que tiene duplicado, ves, tienes el San 0-1,
ha hecho aquello de duplicarse y todo, vale, pues nada, no pasa nada, no pasa nada, no pasa nada,
este sí, venga, ya está, vamos por buen camino, ánimo, ánimo, como digo siempre son gafes del
directo, eh, gráfico del directo. Bien, vamos a trabajar un tendencial en el oro,
¿por qué un tendencial en el oro? Bueno, el oro es un activo bastante tendencial,
aunque también los sistemas mil-reversio pueden funcionar, es decir, no es un activo,
sobre todo en los últimos años, tan tendencial como para excluirlo del mil-reversio, porque
también pasa épocas de bastante congestión, también va bien de haber causa, puede ir bien
en ambos casos, pero a priori es uno de esos sitios donde los tendenciales pueden ir, es que
no hay muchos sitios donde pueden ir los tendenciales de largo plazo, eh, cuidado, de medio plazo,
no hay muchos sitios y en general las materias primas son uno de ellos, en general son uno de
ellos, ¿vale? Y en línea con esto quería enseñaros un sistema que ya está hecho y para aprovechar y
comentaros el material que os voy a entregar, como he dicho, y para eso tengo que abrir un
documento que tengo yo anotado todo esto, ¿vale? Entonces aquí en la revista del julio era esto,
la revista de julio, la revista de julio, porque he estado haciendo un análisis, ya os lo pasaremos
con el material, ¿vale? Pero en definitiva, a ver dónde tengo todo esto, se trata de todas las
revistas del strategy concept, esto teníamos dudas a verdad si darlo o no, porque esto al final no
deja de ser la continuación del stat pero mucho más nuevo, como veis pues fue de 2015-2016,
se dejó de hacer, era de pago, era una revista por suscripción de tele station, bastante interesante
la verdad, nosotros entonces éramos partners y nos la enviaban y bueno pues uno de los crecidos
que hemos hecho es repasar, porque como ya os he comentado es muy buena práctica esto, es decir,
ideas que están hechas hace un tiempo como van ahora, ¿no? Y en términos generales todo está
muy degradado, había un proceso de sobreutilización bastante evidente muchos de ellos, pero sí que
hay dos, tres cosas que mantienen perfectamente el nivel y cuidado, aún así, aunque las que hayan
degradado no pensar que no sirven, porque ellos todos sus revistas, esto lo vamos a entregar en
entero, lo vamos a entregar entero, entero quiere decir que incluye la revista excepto la muestra,
que no sé por qué no hemos conseguido encontrarla, estaba, pero no he conseguido encontrarla, así que
no os la puedo enseñar, ahí solo estará el código y el workspace, en todos viene el material incluido,
que es, todos habían dos o a veces tres sistemas de un bonus comentado, trabajado y viene el workspace,
viene el easy language, tenéis que importar primero el easy language y luego pues abrir el
workspace y os recomiendo encarecidamente leer la revista, no centraros solo en el código,
porque la revista es bastante interesante, en el sentido que explica un poco la idea y además
siempre plantea alguna sugerencia de mejora, es interesante y algunas de ellas seguramente,
por ejemplo, pueden hacer que el sistema incluso funcione ahora, es decir, que era, o sea, está
pensado un poco, como os digo yo en el curso, es para dar ideas, de acuerdo, no pensar en,
ya está, que hay una idea, que una posible idea, entonces es realmente muy, muy, muy interesante,
os recomiendo, os recomiendo que os los leáis todos poco a poco, con el tiempo. ¿Por qué lo
hemos dado finalmente? Bueno, porque no está disponible en ningún sitio, no lo he encontrado,
ni en la página de Terestation he conseguido encontrarlo y por eso hemos dicho, oye, no creo
que nadie vaya a decir nada, con algo que realmente no está disponible ni a la venta,
ni en ningún sitio, entonces, pues, esa ha sido, al final, la decisión, darlo, ¿vale? Ya digo,
es un material de bastante valor, también el de Starlo era, el de Star tiene más información en
cuanto a técnica, podemos decir, pero este a nivel de práctica es realmente muy, muy valioso,
muy valioso, ya digo, están todos los sistemas hechos, ¿vale? Y casualmente, casualmente,
había un sistema en la revista de julio del 15 que os voy a enseñar, que os voy a enseñar y que,
como digo, os entregaremos, ¿eh? Si no, mañana, eso sí que os lo haré, porque solo lo tengo que
empaquetar y ya lo estuve revisando y lo tengo que empaquetar y, pues, me lleva tampoco mucho,
mucho, ya hice ese trabajo que también os voy a entregar, ¿vale? Que es un trabajo de analizar
desde una fecha que le puse yo cargada, que era desde la fecha del workspace, el código mismo
original, tal que datos de rendimiento daba en el log y en el short, qué trades tenía y algún
comentario por mi parte, entonces, bueno, veréis que hay algunos, hay algunos intradiarios que están
perdiendo, pero no los tienen bastante valor, es decir, por ejemplo, bueno, este, por ejemplo,
es el Paraboli, que sé que vais a ver ahora, que está fantástico, pero luego hay algún intradía
con muchísimos trades que ha perdido, por ejemplo, este, que merece la pena darle una vuelta, o este,
el NeckFade, este con 2.704.000 trades y tiene 0.96 de profit factor, merece la pena darle una
vuelta porque, repito, tiene algunas sugerencias y es posible, yo creo que es probable que la
ventaja sea aprovechable con un poco de trabajo, ¿de acuerdo? Hay varios del VIX, eso me comentaba
Juan, bueno, hay algunos que usan el VIX, no operan el VIX, opera el SP, pero derivadas del VIX,
hay intradiarios, hay diarios de largo plazo, hay algunos muy interesantes, este también lo
tenía apuntado para enseñaros hoy, lo enseñaremos probablemente el próximo día, probablemente
trabajaremos este, que es una especie de 1000 reversos, ¿vale? Pero ahora vamos al Paraboli,
esto ya lo digo, os lo entregaré, esto me lleva bastante tiempo hacerlo, pero tiene bastante valor
porque así ves un poquito por dónde van los tiros y que hay alguno que está fatal, por ejemplo,
este, ¿vale? Pero aquellos que tengan 0.90 y pico, sobre todo con muchísimos trades, caso de este,
darle una vuelta, darle una vuelta porque probablemente hay, con algún trabajo,
hay muchos stops, por ejemplo, monetarios, ya sabes lo que pienso, a mejor solucionando
algunas cosas es probable que puedan funcionar, que puedan funcionar, sobre todo repito aquellos
que tienen muchísimas operaciones y que la degradación tampoco es brutal, la degradación
tampoco es brutal, ¿vale? Pero alguno, sobre todo este, por ejemplo, en el oro, os digo,
es tendencial y como venía el pelo para la clase, os lo voy a enseñar, es uno de los dos que,
no, no es este, debía ser Julio Igual, ese es, ¿vale? Ya lo tengo importado el Easy Language,
abro el código, os lo quiero enseñar porque ya hablamos del Paraboli, que además os dije,
os dije que me gustaba y os dije que era un indicador que originariamente el autor lo había
ideado para, para hacer un, esto va en reverse, esto se llama ParabolicSAR, acordaros que os
comenté de la ayuda, ahí lo tenéis explicado, aquí si no, la mejor manera de ir es desde los
indicadores desde aquí, pero si no desde el Easy Language, aquí tenéis en Help, tenéis aquí
Studies and Strategies y aquí están todos, ¿vale? Aquí están todos los indicadores, las estrategias,
tú le pones aquí Parabolic y te va a salir el indicador, la estrategia, te va a ser todo lo que
hay, ves? Parabolic Long Entry, Short Entry, indicador, la función, etcétera, etcétera,
distintas opciones y además normalmente, normalmente viene explicado, ¿vale? Algunos más que otros,
pero normalmente viene explicado y comentado y demás, ¿vale? Está bien el autor que es Wilder,
ya lo hablamos de él, ¿vale? Entonces él siempre lo relató, lo explicó como un mecanismo de giro
basado en tiempo y precio que acelera y que hace esto para el revés, bueno, pues este sistema se
basa en él y es bastante original, es decir, creo que tenía, si no recuerdo mal, pocas variaciones
respecto a la idea original, aplicado a un activo tendencial, espera, voy a cargar directamente el
GC porque va a ir más rápido, ¿vale? Le vamos a cargar, bueno, hasta ahora, Change, bueno, del 2010,
pues 2010, no da igual, seguramente con el GC lo tengo en el caché y abrirá rápido y aquí está el
sistema, que no se ve porque este es el original suyo, que es lo que vamos a hacer, entregaros el
material original, pero voy a pintar las flechitas, él ha ideado unos filtros pero están desactivados,
están desactivados, filtros en mi opinión bastante pobre, nuevamente stop de 2000, aunque es verdad
que el oro, el oro no es uno de esos activos donde más se nota cambiar de porcentaje o no,
¿vale? Es decir, está bien porque al final, como habéis visto, el rango mayor lo tocó hace mucho
tiempo, sí que ha variado mucho de precio pero comparativamente no como el Nasdaq,
dependiendo de cuánto vayamos atrás, pero en términos generales la variación porcentual no
es tan elevada y por eso al final pues no puede aceptar esto los monetarios, aunque ya digo que
en caso de dudas siempre usar ajustados por volatilidad, ¿vale? Bueno, es igual, aquí ya
vemos las líneas un poco más, casi que espérate que te las voy a poner porque es que esto yo sé
por experiencia que luego se ve mucho peor por el vídeo, así en blanco siempre es mejor que este
oscurito, ¿no? Entonces yo creo que ahí ahora se nos va a ver un poco mejor todo, ¿vale? Entonces
esto está, como habéis actualizado, ahora mismo está largo porque esto hace stop and revel, es decir,
está todo el tiempo en el mercado excepto cuando salta el stop loss, parece que 2000 dólares ahora
es un poquito justo, por lo que veo, pero ahora sí no salta tanto tampoco, mirad que no va saltando
tanto, pero sí que es un poquito justo, el indicador, estas líneas azules que veis es el
parabólic, ¿de acuerdo? Es el parabólic que va, como veis, pegándose la tendencia, ¿vale? Bueno,
el sistema no va nada mal, el sistema no va nada mal, teniendo en cuenta, repito, que es un sistema
que estaba en la revista de mayo de junio de 2015, es decir, hace pues ya nueve años prácticamente
que se emitió esta revista y lo he abierto original y que además usa el parabólic prácticamente
virgen, es decir, prácticamente no tienen nada distinto, ¿de acuerdo? Esto es el sistema al uso
del parabólic, si lo metéis vosotros en el oro, que está, como os he dicho, ahora lo podemos probar y
al final pues es un sistema que como es un activo tendencial suele ir bastante bien, ¿vale? Yo le
regularía el stop, ya habéis visto la curva que no está mal, es verdad que lleva unos años bastante
planos, pero eso es, el oro estaba así, es lo que hablábamos antes, aún así pues ha aguantado bien, es
decir, la verdad que estos drawdowns así pues son bastante tendidos, son agradecidos, digamos,
no son drawdowns muy profundos y son bastante llevaderos, podemos decir, ¿vale? Pero ya digo
que esto no tiene simplemente el parabólic directamente metido, esto como os digo para
los que estáis iniciando, esto estaba en 60 minutos, recordar aprovechar también todos estos
elementos precreados que os facilita TrayStation, ¿vale? Parabólic long entry, parabólic short entry,
¿de acuerdo? Todo lo que acaba en entry, todo lo que acaba en exit, ¿de acuerdo? Entonces tú puedes
usar el parabólic long entry, le pones a aceptar, no tocas nada y vais a ver que era básicamente lo
que estaba haciendo ahí, básicamente lo que estaba haciendo ahí, veréis que los trades creo que no
había ninguna optimización, no lo he mirado pero me parece recordar que no, ahora había alguna,
pero ahora que yo recuerde simplemente con el stop este sí que parece que tiene alguna pequeña
diferencia, ¿no? Igual tenía alguna, no lo recuerdo, lo miramos en el código rápido,
el parabólic es normal, nextbar, compro el parabólic stop, es el short, bueno tiene un
trailing, ¿vale? Tiene un trailing, veo aquí, ah bueno, pero solo cuando activa el, no, no,
si no lo activa, no, si no lo activa, no, pues debería ir igual, no sé por qué, a 001, 002,
vale, porque está en 001 creo, por defecto lo pusieron más sensible, vale, lo pusieron más
sensible, vale, para el oro, exacto, ves, está en 002, lo pusieron un poquito más sensible, lo vamos
a poner en 001, que es como está en el sistema y vais a ver que es lo mismo, porque es que, es que
era esto, vale, esto a veces hablamos de, oh, qué complicado, buscar ideas y no necesito gastarme
4000 euros en comprar la strategic one, porque es imposible encontrar ideas, no sé cómo, pues mira,
aquí tienes una, la mar de sencilla, ahí lo tienes, que se puede mejorar, sí claro que se puede
mejorar, puede filtrar, se puede buscarle salidas, pero ya veis que es un sistema que incluso solo
eso, elemento precreado de 3 session metido a grosso modo, sin stop, sin nada, pues está ganando,
vale, que está ganando poco, está justito, pero si queda la sensación que en el largo plazo,
pues como veis obtiene retorno positivo, simplemente usar el parabolic, porque es un
activo que en sí tiene una base bastante tendencial, que es verdad que pasa a periodos
laterales, pero cuando aguje tendencia tira mucho y entonces compensa, vale, esa es un poco la clave,
y ya está, esto como os digo os lo daremos, todo este material creo que tiene mucho valor y os
recomiendo encarecidamente leer la revista de todos, poco a poco, empezás por el principio, con calma,
y ya digo que es bastante interesante, vale, preguntas sobre esto, no, Mario comenta que le
parece interesante, hay impresionantes, sí, sí, el material que estamos intentamos, bueno, intentamos
al valor, porque para eso habéis comprado el curso, entonces al final de eso se trata, hay mucho
hay mucho material, este es realmente el de stat, para aquel que esté iniciando, que se esté iniciando
el tren agonómico prácticamente con el curso o casi, es recomendable leerlo porque tiene bastante
teoría también de mercados, de acuerdo, es decir, viene el rollo dosier, cien páginas cada
uno y tal, y va explicando cosas y luego pone ejemplos, desde ese punto de vista está muy bien,
está muy bien, ni que sea, incluso el que tenga experiencia, yo recomiendo hacer una lectura
diagonal, es decir, bueno, lo abro, lo miro, por si ves que es lo que explica, pues no te interesa,
da igual, este en cambio es muy técnico, este es muy técnico, este ya es para, pero por eso yo
creo que para todos los que ya vayáis, estáis ya pues acabando el curso, os puede aportar mucho
valor, este puede aportar muchísimo, muchísimo valor trabajarlos y además viene con los workspace,
con esto que habéis visto, que no importas, pero leerlos, de acuerdo, leerlos porque es
importante lo que explica, porque al final ellos lo plantean como ideas, cuando enseguen las
curvas está muy bien, pero lo plantean como ejercicios de trabajo. Bien, vamos al oro,
vamos al otro sistema tendencial de base, que hemos hecho aquí, hemos dicho, oye,
¿cuál es el indicador tendencial por excelencia? Yo creo que todo el mundo respondería las medias
móviles, pues vamos a usar las medias móviles, que pocas cosas más simples hay que unas medias
móviles. Bien, la pregunta del millón, si buscáis por internet qué medias móviles usar,
termina o límicos, saldrán 748 artículos, porque siempre es un interno debate, hay medias uso,
y os recomendé, ahí os comenté que nosotros nos solemos decantar por simples, pero que estamos
abiertos a estudiarlo y hemos aprovechado este ejercicio para hacerlo. ¿Cómo podemos hacerlo esto?
Bueno, pues la manera más sencilla es un poco del mismo modo que abordamos las salidas, como veis,
están aquí metidas porque las usamos para este ejercicio, es decir, plantear distintas
alternativas. Esto en EasyLanguage se puede hacer con estructuras if-then, pero se hace muy fácil
con la switch, con el switch case, ¿por qué? Porque, ves, yo aquí ahora lo dejo todo comprimido
dentro de este begin-end y queda ahí de coña, cerradito con la media que yo haya escogido,
¿de acuerdo? Le pongo un input que es la media, y con eso elijo el tipo de media. Si vale uno,
case 1, si vale 2, case 2, si vale 3, case 3, si vale 4, case 4, ¿vale? Y ahí hemos ido metiendo medias
a saco a saco, es decir, un poco sin sentido casi, es decir, por supuesto hemos metido las más
razonables o las más típicas, pero hemos ido ya, ya que estábamos, ya que estábamos hemos ido
veniéndonos, veniéndonos arriba, y os recomiendo buscar información sobre ellas porque si me paro
a explicaros las todas, pues vamos a tardar mucho. Recordar también en EasyLanguage que podéis
abrir las funciones, podéis ir a las definiciones si son funciones suyas, que hay algunas que no
son suyas y por lo tanto no estarán, pero esta sí lo es, la mama. La mama y la fama son medias
de mesa, que era un software muy muy famoso que se hicieron bastante populares en una época, son
del tipo adaptativas, yo os hablé un poco de ellas, yo os hablé que me gusta mucho la cama,
que es la que viene antes, Kaufman Moving Average, esta no sé si es suya o no, esta está sacada del
libro, pero creo que estaba la cama también, pero hemos usado la original de, la original de
Kaufman, ¿vale? Pero creo que está, creo que dentro hay una función cama, o sea que tranquilos,
estoy casi seguro que si yo pongo aquí hay un cama series, ¿ves lo que os decía? Ahí lo tenéis,
no es broma, no sale, pues no, pues yo pensaba que sí, estaba que es seguro, ¿no te suena a ti
Alberto que hay un cama? ¿no te suena a ti que hay un cama? Pues se ve que no, bueno pues nada,
es, pero será el nuestro, será el nuestro porque no está aquí en la Distance Strategies,
pues me extrañamos, a mí me sonaba muchísimo que estaba, ¿eh? Sí, sí, no sé, pues no estará,
no estará, bueno, ya que el que la quiera se la paso, si no encontrará mucha, ¿eh? Kaufman Macadosh
Enes, ¿no? No, va a seguir, tampoco hay nada de Kaufman, pues nada, pues no está la cama, pues nada,
aquí la estáis viendo ahora, este es el original de Kaufman, de hecho viene con el libro y es fácil
de encontrar, ¿eh? Aquellos, recordad los foros de TrayStation, ¿eh? Tras ahí los foros, buscáis,
hay 700 páginas, bando de cama y cualquier cosa, es decir, los foros de TrayStation son
extremadamente útiles porque son solo de clientes, claro, es que ahora ya hablo un poco más de código
porque vamos avanzando, ¿vale? Insisto que el código es una herramienta, pero es una herramienta
que hay que usar, que no sea lo más importante, no quiere decir que no haya que usarla, ¿vale?
Entonces el cama es otra media adaptativa, simplemente otra media adaptativa,
vamos a enseñar el gráfico, la mama y fama que vienen de esta función, ya os lo he comentado,
era de mesa y luego pues tienes la Xaveratz, por cierto hay otra Xaveratz que es Xaveratz
original, que simplemente una está más, la exponencial tiene como en coeficiente,
una está más acercada que la otra, bueno, yo por efecto uso esta, pero están las dos y luego
hemos ido mezclando simple con exponencial, simple con cama, simple con mama, exponencial
con simple, simple con exponencial, un poco ahí, como os digo, dándole vueltas a todo, porque al
final esto una vez está puesto no cuesta nada, es decir, esto está hecho y puedes meter medias,
tienes aquí 19 medias, 19 cruces de medias, ¿vale? 19 cruces de medias que simplemente se controlan
con este input, si yo pongo uno uso simple, si pongo dos uso exponenciales, si pongo tres uso
cama, si pongo cuatro, fama más mama, etcétera, etcétera, de esta manera controlo un poco todo
esto, también hemos implementado la posibilidad de que sea cruce o no, que sea simplemente que
la media sea mayor, esto cuando hay salidas es importante, normalmente es mejor con cruce,
yo lo he trabajado así, pero bueno, hemos dejado la opción, pero ni he valorado otra cosa, y bueno,
pues ya está, hay distintos filtros de valoridad, porque hay un dungeon implementado también,
hay un dungeon implementado para, en caso de que además del cruce de medias se quiere usar un
dungeon, un dungeon es un canal, es decir, que una vez cruzado, además yo le exija superar unos
máximos, de momento no lo he implementado, lo dejo como un filtro, y bueno, esta es la versión 1,
espérate, tengo la, aquí tengo la 2 metida, no la tengo la 2 metida, aquí no he metido la 2 aún,
bueno, pues ahora la meto, la tengo en el, la tengo metida en el otro, lo que pasa es que si,
bueno, me da igual, me da igual porque eso lo tengo todo guardado, esto lo tengo todo guardado,
aquí meto, a ver, la curso, entraría a 02, aunque no sé si lo tengo bien con parámetros,
bueno, me da igual, como luego lo voy a, luego lo voy a meter, me da igual, lo dejo así por defecto,
a ver que esté, como digo, hay inputs para si quiero activar largos o cortos, esto está pensado
más para multicharts, porque aquí puedo hacerlo de otra manera, la media, slow y fast, que ahora
os explique una cosa, la media, que campo uso, el cruce, si hay dungeon, si hay dungeon, todos estos
son de dungeon, pero no sé, no se uso de momento, lo mismo si quiero esto, nuestro monetario típico
puesto ahí por ATR clásico, esto lo ponemos siempre nosotros por defecto, si no quiero activarlo
activo, si no, no activo, pero como vamos a probar las salidas, pues lo he dejado desactivado,
y el money management, que aquí lo hemos desactivado, porque en el oro eso que os decía,
se puede trabajar bien desactivado y lo hemos dejado desactivado, y luego hay una cosa bastante
interesante y bastante avanzada, y que sí que esto no lo vamos a explicar, porque es el hecho
de poder pintar a través de una estrategia, esto en principio en Easy Language no se puede hacer
por defecto, es decir, solo puede pintar un indicador, hay lenguajes que permiten que una
estrategia pinten el gráfico, pero mediante objetos se puede hacer, aquí tenemos un código que lo
hace, de tal manera que viene muy bien para ver las medias, ya no os lo voy a activar para hacer eso,
también hay filtros de horarios, pero no lo hemos activado, y los filtros de volatilidad,
que de momento no están activados, estas barras que es Alberto, que no me acuerdo, al final de todo
barras, para la DX y la TR, podríamos haber usado el de arriba, vale, ok, ok, esto lo dejo así,
ahora le he puesto que pinte, y ahí vais a ver que automáticamente cuando acabe, claro, le va a costar
un poco más, pinta las medias, estas medias me las está pintando el propio sistema, vale, esto
porque viene bien, esto consume muchos recursos y además a veces si le vas cambiando acaba
estando bugueando el ordenador, pero para hacer esto que vamos a hacer ahora viene muy bien,
porque simplemente cambiando el input, cambiando la media, me la va a cambiar, vale, me la va a
cambiar, y yo, pues bueno, quiero ahora enseñaros alguna, antes que nada, siempre un consejo,
vale, siempre que uséis un sistema de medias, en este caso de cruce de medias, os recomiendo
encarecidamente usar un truco en el código que consiste simplemente en vincular una con otra,
aquí lo hemos hecho con la slow, vale, hemos fijado la slow, vale, y a la fast le restamos,
o sea, a ver, empiezo por el principio, yo en el código, en inputs, tengo dos valores para la media,
un slow average y un fast average, que son las medias, pero eso no es la media realmente que yo
pinto en el gráfico, la slow sí que es la que pinto en el gráfico, le pongo 46, ahora os explicaré
por qué, vale, y veis que cuando hago el cálculo de cualquiera de las slow, efectivamente como
periodo le paso el slow, vale, en cambio la fast, cuando yo calculo la media fast, la calcule como
la calcule para los distintos case que hay, no le paso el parámetro de la fast, le paso el periodo,
perdón, para ser más exacto, de la slow menos la fast, de tal manera que en esta configuración que
veis aquí de 46 y 9, las medias que realmente están en el gráfico y usan el sistema para
operar son la 46 como slow y como fast usa 46 menos 9, es decir, 37, perdón, 37, para ver si
estabais acentos, vale, entonces de tal manera que si yo le pongo 45 es la 1, vale, lo vais a ver ahora,
yo le voy a poner ahora solo para que lo veáis, estoy ahora con el 2, le voy a poner al fast 45 y
vais a ver que me va a pintar la media de 1, va a tardar un poco porque esto es así, vale, esto
simplemente es para facilitar los procesos de optimización de iteración, vale, porque si no
duplico medias y hago medias absurdas, porque si pongo la fast 20 y al slow 30, me entiendes,
o se optimizo 10 a 20, 10 a 20, cruzo medias que son absurdas, de esta manera veis ahora que la
ha pintado aquí la 1, esta la ha dejado igual y esta es la 1, vale, de acuerdo, y el sistema ahora
está operando con eso, con la 1, que es lo mismo que no tener media, es el cierre, la media de 1,
simple, claro, es el cierre, es el cierre, de acuerdo, entonces de esta manera yo
mejoro mi proceso de eficiencia, vale. ¿Cómo hemos planteado este sistema? De entrada,
en un sistema intradidario, cuando uno trabaja en un sistema de medias, en barras diarias,
siempre se recomienda usar períodos que tengan que ver con alguna pauta del mercado, por ejemplo,
pues unas semanas sabemos que son cinco días de mercado, por ejemplo, sabemos que un mes son
22 días, sabemos que un año son 250 más o menos elaborables y podemos hacer por ahí, o que sea
un trimestre, un cuatrimestre, entendéis un poco la idea, ¿no? o la mitad de un trimestre, es decir,
podemos hacer cálculos, pero es recomendable porque al final una media no deja de ser un
ciclo, una media es una de las maneras más sencillas que hay de normalizar, hay de normalizar,
de eliminar el ruido, simplemente yo trato de dibujar la tendencia de ese mercado agrupando
valores en ellos, por lo tanto trato de de esta manera aprovecharme de esas tendencias, en este
caso lo hacemos con dos medias, como os decía, y que ahora mismo son simples, porque yo he elegido
la 46, bueno, porque en intradía esto que os digo de los períodos recurrentes es un poco más
complicado y nosotros de entrada partimos de la hipótesis de usar como lenta la media de una sesión,
vale, una sesión, en este caso en 30 minutos una sesión son justamente 46 velas, podría usar
otras, sí podría usar otra, pero hemos partido con esta hipótesis de trabajo, ¿de acuerdo?
entonces hemos permitido optimizar la fast y el tipo de media para hacer este estudio que os digo,
que ahora lo vamos a enseñar, pero he bloqueado la slowing 46, que es la que veis granate lila,
porque insisto eso es la media de una sesión, vale, una sesión, 46 velas, ¿de acuerdo?
Bien, vamos a ver estos primeros estudios de las medias, vamos a ver primero estos estudios de las
medias, el sistema en sí no tiene nada más, perdón, antes para acabar de explicar, el sistema
como os digo por repasarlo, luego hablaremos de los filtros pero ahora mismo no me importan,
el núcleo principal del sistema es un cruce de medias que como veis o como os he dicho puede
valorar por muchos y es un simple cruce, cuando hay cruces la señal que desencadena la posibilidad
de comprar que es con long y con short no es más que la rápida cruce por encima de la lenta y vice
versa para el lado corto y a partir de ahí simplemente el código para desencadenar las
órdenes es si con long is true, es decir, si ha habido un cruce, aquí implemento la salida al
lado contrario porque evidentemente si yo he cortado al lado largo le implemento esto,
esto es por si yo tengo inhabilitadas, si no hago stop and reverse que lo he pensado así por eso
lo he puesto, porque si hago stop and reverse como habéis visto antes con el parabolic entre
este son abrir largos y abrir cortos ya cierra en el otro lado no es obligatorio pero es buena
práctica hacerlo, es buena práctica hacerlo porque así yo permito al sistema salir sin necesidad de
entrar, aunque en este caso la condición sea la misma podría no serlo, podría no serlo, aquí
habilitó la posibilidad de que si uso donchat que lo tengo en false pues lógicamente implemento,
calculo el canal y todo esto y aquí hay un tema ahora que no no iré a cuento simplemente por
evitar lecturas falsas y temas de programación que ahora mismo no viene a cuento y aquí ya está
simplemente si tengo permitido abrir largos y estamos en la sesión que esto es al final el
filtro horario que no he usado pero lo tengo en el código para que lo podáis usar si lo deseáis
es decir que para abrir tenga que estar en unas horas en un tendencial puro tiene menos sentido
filtrar horario vale contra más largo el recorrido tenga el trade menos sentido tiene pero el sistema
está como casi todos los que hemos ido enseñando para desarrollar implementados para probar
distintas opciones son son códigos de desarrollo de acuerdo no son códigos de operativas son códigos
de desarrollo y por lo tanto yo no hay problema en implementar 70 posibilidades luego puedo
usarlas o no usarlas ya me permiten investigar me permiten investigar y analizar distintas cosas
pero no quiere decir que las tenga que usar esto automáticamente como yo le he puesto de 0 0 a 23
59 pues no actúa porque siempre es true como siempre es true pues siempre opera vale por
horario pero podría cambiarlo lo mismo con el filtro y el filtro atr que si lo tengo en 0 es true
por lo tanto no actúa vale y lo mismo con el don chat vale entonces automáticamente pues
simplemente tiro la orden la orden de lotes al precio del canal el caso que use don chat y si
no uso don chat lo tira a mercado que es como está ahora si yo usar a don chat en el momento
que hay el cruce de medias que pasaría pues aquí yo imaginaros que el don chat fuera que me lo
invento absolutamente tras el cruce el don chat estuviera aquí pues podría un stop aquí para
vender aquí pero insisto que de momento lo hecho sólo al cruce es decir una vez cierra la cruza
vende a mercado vale esto es como está configurado el sistema ahora mismo pero está preparado para
que podáis probar distintas alternativas no es mala práctica probar un don chat de suele
mejorar retrasa la entrada pero mejora bastante los períodos laterales no deja ser un filtro
vale podemos hemos implementado filtro por don chat hemos entrado filtro por volatilidad y filtro por
adx se pueden buscar otros si se pueden buscar otros ya al final lo comento vale se pueden buscar
otros pero hemos implementado estos tres para daros ya algunas herramientas y a partir de ahí podéis
seguir y el lado corto pues es espejo este sistema es espejo podría separarse largos y cortos podría
pero en un activo en las materias primas suele ser buena práctica no hacerlo pero sí que podríamos
porque vamos a conseguir 5.000 trades y si queremos 10.000 los conseguimos entonces al
final le podríamos hacer pero es buena práctica de desarrollo y la idea en principio estaría
más validada estaría más validada que fuera espejo se llama no porque en principio el oro
al igual que las divisas no tiene un motivo especial de sesgo de volatilidad como si tienen
los bonos y la y las acciones que es más evidente el oro puede tener subidas y bajadas con volatilidad
recuerdo no no hay un sesgo claro en un sesgo claro como lo hay en las acciones que es clarísimo y
también normalmente los bonos entonces a partir de ahí a priori trabajamos espejo pero podemos
implementarlo y por eso hay estas dos variables estos dos inputs true false de decir yo lo le
pongo false en el corto y sólo va largo le pongo false en el largo y sólo va corto de acuerdo de
decir puedo si quiero habilitarlo para uno de los dos lados del mercado y poco más el código no
tiene no tiene mayor historia aquí tiene el tema de pintar vale es lo que os digo esto que este
código simplemente pinta vale que tiene una variable que calcula cuando está optimizando pues
que no no pinte de acuerdo entonces pero aquí con esto pinta las medias y más esto este código de
que el final es el encargado de pintar las medias vale muy sencillo un sistema de cruce de medias
al que le hemos habilitado la posibilidad de tres filtros de entrada y que mediante todo el código
que ya conocéis de salidas vamos a probar distintas salidas con otro código externo que
en tres sesiones esto se puede hacer de manera muy práctica vale de momento ahora lo es activo vale
lo es activo y dejo simplemente a bruto la media de acuerdo bueno estaba ahora está con una media
cierre contra media porque le he puesto el 45 decirle puesto que la media es rápida que opere es 1 y
la media lenta 46 entonces pues va a 1 contra 46 esto está hasta el viernes hasta el viernes
podemos cargarlo hasta hoy no tiene mayor problema para ver cómo va ahora que siempre hace como
gracia no como gracia verlo en tiempo real nosotros hemos trabajado por temas de procesamiento de
datos hasta hasta ahora vale y entonces pues vamos a ver algunos datos que lógicamente he preparado
antes porque si no sería bastante bastante inviable entonces sería bastante inviable por lo tanto por
eso pues yo ahora lo he preparado previamente aquí tengo algunos algunos datos el tendencial del oro
aquí tengo esto no aquí no es perdón te decía loro aquí tengo las optis sergi soy yo
luego veremos algunas cosas de por aquí pero aquí de momento tengo las medias no tengo las medias
tengo las medias tengo las medias vale tengo las medias hemos hecho vamos por el principio
vamos por partes que diría jack bien excel que ya habéis visto acuerdo que ya habéis visto donde
proveniente de tres es el recogemos datos in sample datos auto sample datos all data aquí
no he puesto ficha fallo mío debería de haberla pero no la he hecho se me perdone y os explico lo
que hemos hecho simplemente como os decía la slow queda fijada en 46 y ha optimizado la
faz desde 1 hasta 45 más de 45 no puede ser porque acordaros que le resto la la faz al slow y si le
resto 46 pues da 0 y la media de 0 estáis de acuerdo conmigo que no se puede representar en
un gráfico entonces sin usar para operar entonces de 1 a 45 que equivale a usar la slow siempre en
46 y la faz desde 1 hasta 45 de acuerdo eso es lo que lo que hago al optimizarla al optimizarla
de esta de esta manera y con los 19 creo que eran no 11 eran 19 tipos de media de acuerdo
19 pero como sólo he guardado 100 ya porque ya he querido no no hacerla demasiado amplia de guardarlas
todas digo bueno que me cogen los 100 mejores y hasta vale y automáticamente he hecho este esta
primera optimización lo primero que vemos aquí en la ficha un in sample es que obtenemos unos
rebundes bastante pobres hay que hay que ir al número 11 para obtener un positivo está bien
que es la media faz 20 que recuerdo insisto se resta se resta con la combinación 11 vale fijaros
que en sample todas las medias que me salen son 3 8 11 aquí 1 que acordaros es simple simple
pero ahora vemos 3 8 11 se repite muchísimo 3 8 11 prácticamente hasta aquí casi todo es 3
8 11 que era 3 3 es cama sorpresa 3 es cama aquí que lo tengo escondido 3 es cama con cama vale 8
es exponencial con simple bastante interesante verdad y coherente no es es hombre la rápida
exponencial y la lenta simple verdad que sí es una cosa que le que la vemos la vemos razonable
no es razonable y luego la 11 que es cama de rápida con slow con normal con simple de slow
también lo vemos bastante razonable también lo vemos bastante razonable vamos a poner esto en
el gráfico para que lo veáis para que lo veáis un poco en la práctica veis que pasa con una media
muy rápida con una lenta esto pasa continuas señales falsas en el lateral aquí le hemos
puesto ahora como hemos dicho tengo el excel yo aquí arriba vale porque no puedo ponerlo todo lo
pongo aquí arriba pero yo os digo lo que voy poniendo bueno no vais a ver recordar que el
parámetro que pongo bueno por eso lo pinto en el gráfico y viene muy bien la media slow siempre
es 46 vale la faz si ponemos aquí la que una de las que nos salía por ejemplo bueno la que ha
salido mejor en in sample vale sería la 7 vale con la 3 a 7 con la 3 y esto las medidas no usan
nada más no he filtrado nada no tengo salidas nada de acuerdo simplemente estoy evaluando las
medias voy a stop and reverse todo el rato del mercado quiero ver a ver qué media es la que
mejor sigue la tendencia del oro de acuerdo esto es un poco la idea que luego puedo a lo mejor
afinarla una vez simplemente filtros podría ser pudiera ser pero yo de entrada quiero ver un poco
la media al final una media no deja de ser el resumen de la tendencia de un activo estamos de
acuerdo no deja de ser o trata de resumir entonces digo bueno yo no he explicado desde dónde he
cargado el gráfico ahora os lo enseño vale quiero ver qué gráfico saqué que qué media representa
mejor al oro no bueno de momento he puesto esta que la 3 hemos dicho que era cama con cama y la
7 que recordar la resto de 46 es decir realidad es la de 39 es decir es una media bastante lenta
bastante lenta lo vais a ver es una media que se parece mucho a la a ella misma se parece mucho
vale lo que pasa que son medias cama que son medias adaptativas que en este valor no se nota
mucho luego veréis una una que se va a notar más porque será como más lenta más rápida pero
fijaros que la media cama es adaptativa dependiendo de la volatilidad que hay se acerca más caros
aquí que se mantienen muy separadas y en cambio aquí están juntas no realmente no van no siguen
la misma sin cronía porque a tener un periodo distinto su nivel de ajustes distinto pero se
parecen bastante se parecen bastante vale y son medias pues realmente que provocan situaciones
un tanto extrañas dejarnos aquí que ha sido casi capaz de vender en el máximo simplemente con una
media no dices cómo puede ser no bueno esos son particularidades de las medias adaptativas son una
sería imposible pues las medias adaptativas al llevar un ciclo llevar una parámetro que ajusta
la media que cuando decimos que ajusta la media quiere decir que regula su velocidad vale decir
una media simple es una medida aritmética de 10 periodos todos los 10 periodos valen lo mismo de
10 de 20 de 50 de los que sea en la media exponencial cada los más cercanos valen lo mismo valen más
pero por un coeficiente estable entonces la exponencia le da más importancia a los recientes
pero de manera proporcional siempre igual y lo mismo para una ponderada etcétera en cambio este
tipo ya sean las ya sea la cama sea la mesa la fama tienen algún tipo de cálculo distinto que
trata de modificar la velocidad y en base a que criterio básicamente a la volatilidad ya
habrá gobelas velas decir cuando hay más volatilidad pues le dan más margen y tienen
estas particularidades esto sirve para algo vamos a verlo vamos a verlo si esto sirve para algo
hombre para algo sirve para algo sirve no pero recordar que sólo son dos medias sólo son dos
medias largo y corto ganan los ambos lados del mercado profit factor bajo pero cuidado que
estamos con comisiones no lo he dicho ahora lo digo he puesto 15 dólares de penalización es
más que razonable le he puesto 5 dólares de comisión y 10 de slipage que es un tick un
tick entero vale es razonable es bastante razonable 15 dólares de penalización por operación quiere
decir que es 30 por lado fijaros que yo tengo un average un average trade de 50 vale que si
le sumara los 30 que me lo han dicho serían 80 yo a mí me gusta trabajar así hay hay autores que
trabajan sin comisiones yo personalmente no le veo ninguna ventaja de este criterio no le veo no le
veo ellos dicen que así valuas la señal en bruto sí sí vale pues en bruto pero de esta manera si tú
haces comparación cuando haces un proceso de optimización de análisis al final estás comparando
vale si yo no tengo en cuenta esto todas las combinaciones que están aquí y que pueden
variar el número de trades desde un máximo de 4700 hasta un mínimo de 2500 y porque sólo he
guardado 100 vale pero es bastante rango casi no llega pero se acerca a doblar se acerca a doblar
tendrían el mismo la misma penalidad no es no es lo mismo de acuerdo los dos mismos al final el
hecho de operar más o menos tiene un coste y yo creo que es más buena práctica implementarlo hay
gente que en fases iniciales como esta le gusta no meterlo nosotros solemos meterlo en todo el
proceso pero yo os lo explico como siempre hecho en todo el curso de distintos puntos de vista y
ellos entienden que así se evalúa la ventaja en bruto yo creo que aquí queda claro que hay
ventaja es decir queda muy claro que aquí hay una ventaja porque estamos en un sistema totalmente
simétrico que sólo compra y vende cuando hay un cruce de medias y que así ha ganado dinero además
bastante dinero con un profit factor bajo si un tendencial en 30 minutos con 5409 trades para
tener un profit factor bajo eso es así sería mejor más alto si sería mejor pasar de 1 20 pero
bueno estamos ahí de momento en 1 en 1 13 vale notar aquí recordar que no tengo que ser monetaria
por eso sí que puedo comparar en bruto el dinero más bien que el porcentaje de hecho ahora aquí no
tiene sentido mirar porcentaje no tiene sentido mirar porcentaje fijaros que este estas medias
cama al ser tan cercanas tienen una pequeña paradoja de ahí que la curva sea relativamente
estable para ser un tendencial que tiene un periodo ahí muy malo de años además estos son muchos
esos son 8 7 8 años que tiene un ratio de aciertos tendencial pero no muy tendencial
porque porque la media cama como habéis visto ajustada de esta manera permite hacer cosas tan
surrealistas como esta no que casi ha vendido en el máximo que lógicamente un tendencial nunca
hace no es normal no es una media o sea sólo esto ya no hacer cosas raras de acuerdo es decir uno
puede buscar usos distintos al indicador pero si uno busca un tendencial esto no es un tendencial
a un tendencial no hace esto es decir empecemos por ahí pero bueno estamos viendo un poco las
primeras para que las las veamos para para para un ejercicio de comprensión del sistema y de
análisis vale un detalle muy muy importante un detalle muy importante que tenemos aquí es que las
que a ver aquí como tengo el más 30 sumo con rob acordaros incluido robur es la teoría como
os decía en general todos tienen bastante bajo no vamos a probarlos todos pero mira sé que aquí
veo por ejemplo por curiosidad este 1 8 es como muy distinto que curiosamente es el que tiene
mayor profit perfecto pero dejaros que tiene un robur es muy bajo que quiere decir que en los
últimos años ha ido mal esa opinión no es buena señal verdad abajo tenemos el resumen acordaros
que lo ponemos siempre y ahí vemos que tenemos una mediana de 42 en el robur es con un peor valor
de 71 negativo y un mejor valor de 143 un valor de 42 la verdad que no es tan malo como parece
sobre todo teniendo en cuenta lo que luego os enseñaré el motivo esto hablamos en una teoría
sobre ello y quiero insistir ahora que porque es muy muy importante tenéis que analizar los
datos yo expresamente no lo he hecho ahora que quería llevaros a esta encrucijada y entonces
analizarlo vale pero acordaros lo que os dije hay que ver el gráfico hay que entender los datos y
revisar si son coherentes vale por eso por ejemplo hemos empezado en 2006 nosotros tenemos bases de
datos de tic data que llegan más lejos hasta 2003 de buena calidad pero aquí por por un tema de
procesamiento porque es mucho más lento cuando usas datos de tic data he cargado desde 2006
voy a copiaros esta ventana ahora para hacer dos cosas una de ellas simplemente es cargar
cargar un poquito más de histórico porque vais a ver cómo la base de datos es absolutamente
lamentable vale absolutamente lamentable se vuelve absolutamente lamentable si yo aquí le cargo
un poquito más estoy aquí pues le voy a poner un año más vale le voy a poner un año más han
salido ya las alineaciones alberto todavía no las alineaciones tenemos alineaciones ya o no
todavía no aquí tenéis la aquí tenéis la aquí tenéis el motivo veis este queso gruyer vale que
como este lo voy a lo voy a luego lo voy a luego lo voy a copiar no pasa nada lo quito todo porque
quiero quiero que veáis bien el código hay el activo lo podía haber hecho antes me hubiera
cargado más rápido pero no lo he hecho veis ahí veis ahí veis en la base de datos eso es una
porquería nos sirve para ir al lavabo con ello por primero en un papel y usarlo de papel higiénico
pero poco más veis esto es un desastre a los que velas ahí esto es un desastre esto no se puede
usar chicos vale no se puede usar para tratar de evaluar una ventaja en este activo carvach
y carvachado recordaros si meto porquería a tomar viento entonces aquí donde empieza a hacerse
decente justo en diciembre de el 6 que es donde cargamos es ahí que ya está bien lo vais a ver lo
vais a ver se nota se nota además fijaros la distancia aquí veis la distancia de sesiones que
menos hay en ese cap a partir de hemos cargado vale 1 del 12 del 6 vale hemos cargado desde ahí
si tuviera más datos cargaría más podía cargar más pero ya está bien 16 está muy bien estamos
hablando en un 30 día incluso podría ser menos vale cierro esto y vuelvo a donde está ese ha sido
el motivo vale entonces segunda cosa que os decía el tema del in sample y el auto sample esta análisis
lo tengo hecho aquí a la izquierda no no he ido antes expresamente porque quería ir ahora cuando
llegáramos a ver esto es decir oye 42 de media y todos los que me salen arriba me sale muy bajos
me sale muy bajos esto quiere decir que no vale que el sistema no tiene capacidad predictiva que
qué opináis creéis que sí que esto ya descartaría la capacidad predictiva del sistema la respuesta es
no pero también os digo que muchos autores os dirán que sí mi opinión de manera muy equivocada vale
porque porque al final especialmente en un tendencial un tendencial depende mucho de la
tendencia malgame el juego de palabras pero que todos los sistemas dependen de su tipo de mercado
pero igual que un mil reversión que haya poco movimiento le puede perjudicar pero aún así puede
ser capaz de moverse el rango porque normalmente siempre compra más cerca de mínimos y vende más
cerca de máximos un tendencial si no hay rango lo tiene prácticamente imposible a lo que pueda
aspirar es a no perder a aspirar a no perder o a no operar incluso pero ganarlo tiene imposible
entonces al final tenemos que hacer un análisis del activo y entender esto que a que antes voy
a poner este 20 11 vale porque este sí que es uno de los pocos que aquí arriba demuestra tener muy
buen resultado bueno había dicho antes de poner un 8 pero la pongo el 20 11 os explico la tendencia
luego probamos esto vale vamos a ver este 20 11 que realmente tengo mucha curiosidad por verlo
la verdad 20 11 estamos aquí por dar que la media simple no se toca vamos a ver qué es el 11 20
recordar que es el periodo que yo le resto a 46 por lo tanto va a ser la media de 26 con la media
de 46 no tan forzado como antes y se 11 que es cama contra simple vale cama contra simple
interesante bastante interesante una media más cercana que es la que desencadena la señal la
que va más pegada entre comillas al precio más adaptativa y en cambio la media de fondo que es
toda una sesión acordaros 46 velas simple suena suena suena bien suena razonable suena razonable
aquí lo veis pintado aquí veis la media efectivamente como veis aunque es aparentemente
mucho más lenta como es adaptativa veis se pega bastante más al precio se pega bastante más al
precio ahora sí que ocurre que este tipo de sistema si no tiene una salida que luego le pondremos
cuando tienen estos giros en vertical que el oro es bastante tendiente bastante tendiente hacerlo
vale sobre todo por noticias cosas así ahí es donde se puede notar alguna salida normalmente
no va a utilizar los salidas un tendencial pero estos giros en vertical que te hacen
polvo que jate el dinero que venías ganando aquí al final lo devuelves todo para ponerte
corto y ahora encima volver al lado largo y ahora volver al corto no pero aquí lo que nos resultaba
curioso es que realmente sí que en auto sample había mantenido el rendimiento del sample esto
porque es bueno pues porque este tipo de media más adaptativa ha ido mejor en este mercado
justamente esa es la gracia lo que pretende la adaptativa ciertamente parece que en cierta medida
lo consigue en cierta medida lo consigue la pregunta relacionada con el tema pregunta pregunta
francis los datos históricos se podrían utilizar si unimos los extremos de los gaps al estilo del
ro del rolo bueno pero es que esto ya está unido o sea podrías podría ser o sea al final tú tienes
que conseguir una buena base de datos si no te la dan tienes que conseguir otra aquí la verdad no
vale la pena complicarse francis porque desde 2006 a 2024 ya tenemos muchos datos vale no me hace
falta pero evidentemente si yo no tuviera buenos datos tenía que conseguirlos tenía que conseguirlos
bien en otro proveedor de datos de otra plataforma o bien comprándolos o cambiando de proveedor como
digo porque muchos proveedores al final pero evidentemente la batería prima hay que cuidarla
esto ya lo comentamos en la teoría brevemente para ver un poco aquí el sistema pues bueno vemos que
aquí ha ido mejor en este periodo más adaptativo también en el pasado ha ido bien porque me he
dejado intencionadamente este análisis mira voy con ello ahora vale lo voy a hacer grande para
entender para tratar de explicarme mejor vale esto es el gráfico del oro en el mismo periodo
que está cargado a la derecha en el entradía pero en velas mensuales para poder verlo todo
porque si no pues no no me llegaría no la pantalla para que lo viera es todo además voy a volver a
esto porque siempre lo hago porque me gusta pero para el directo no viene ahí se ve mejor lo mismo
con las líneas las líneas que las voy a pintar les voy a quitar transparencia las voy a poner
de absoluto blanco para que así tengáis un desprendimiento de retina del brillo que os va
a provocar la media y la raya y la veáis que son estas dos líneas bien la línea de la derecha
divide el histórico entre primera parte in sample vale es decir a ver vamos a intentar con esa arte
que sabéis ya porque ya ya lo habéis visto ese gran arte que me ha dado dios capacidades de dibujo
vale esto de aquí es auto sample vale y todo esto todo e olvidaros de esta raya ahora esto sería
en sample esta óptica habéis visto era así esta esta era así 30 por ciento detrás vale exactamente
era así toda esta esta parte vale toda esta parte que os voy a pintar ahora con un cuadrado en color
azul toda esta era in sample toda esta y la de la derecha era auto sample queda claro verdad que
vemos que vemos aquí cogramos todos los dibujitos y demás que vemos aquí hombre vemos dos partes
muy distintas el de la derecha apenas tiene un único tramo de tendencia vale apenas tiene un
único tramo de tendencia que es este y luego tiene un absoluto lateral que ahora está resolviendo
y tú me puedes decir hombre alguno alguno tiene tiene tiene tramos en algún trámito si algunos
son aprovechables te digo que no puede tener este puede tener este incluso estos vale vale bien pero
porque os he marcado esos esos cuadrados rojos porque fijaros en esa similitud de acuerdo tienen
tanto el periodo en sample como el periodo auto sample tiene un periodo que vamos a considerar
hostil para un tendencial que no quiere decir que ahí no vaya a ganar nunca porque esto es mensual y
ahí hay intra intra pero al final el mercado es fractal quiere decir que aunque han habido tramos
de tendencia buenos ahí en general el mercado ha tendido a volver mucho y a ser bastante sucio
entraría y es así es así también lo veríamos lo puedo poner en un momento con un aunque aunque
lo que os decía antes no en un indicador de en un en un oro no se ve ese sesgo de volatilidad tan
tan claro es distinto vale con relación a los a la bolsa aquí la volatilidad es más variable le
pongo sobre la volatilidad de un año no entonces aquí cuesta cuesta de ver cuesta de ver aquí de
hecho se ve bastante bastante volatilidad que eso a priori es bueno pero la verdad que no nos aporta
mucha información pero quito porque nos voy a marear más que otra cosa entonces lo que vemos es
un periodo que a priori es potencialmente hostil y con un pequeño tramo de tendencia el problema
que tiene este periodo de la derecha que es el auto sample repito es que la relación entre el
periodo hostil y periodo favorable está muy descompensada de acuerdo en cambio aquí es
todo lo contrario aquí fijaros qué tramos de tendencia tenemos todo esto es simplemente
espectacular donde ha sido facilísimo ganar dinero con un potencial incluso aquí incluso aquí incluso
aquí al final llegó el periodo malo también ha tenido un periodo que le ha costado en sample
pero proporcionalmente auto sample tiene más esto es uno de los motivos por lo que muchas
veces como os expliqué en la teoría nosotros hacemos más 30 es decir auto sample detrás como
os he explicado ahora y menos 30 que es auto sample delante que qué caso era este bueno en este
caso era esta otra línea aquí quería auto sample este periodo y in sample todo este todo el bar o
emitir la línea aquí pasa todo lo contrario tengo un in sample con dos periodos realmente hostiles
vale y algún tramo de tendencia aprovechable que está más equilibrado que antes pero que sigue
estando desequilibrado porque al final tenemos esto y a uno en medio y tal pero tenemos dos
tramos potencialmente malos y un periodo auto sample que es el paraíso que es el paraíso por lo tanto
aquí cabría esperar que cualquier optimización sobre este periodo en el auto sample fuera la
leche es así vamos a verlo porque hemos hecho esa optimización también esta es la auto sample a la
derecha vale y esta otra es auto sample a la izquierda y sorpresa aquí todos los periodos
otros samples son absolutamente la hostia hecho es que si vamos abajo el peor el peor da positivo
el peor periodo de los 100 la peor combinación de medias la media 1 aquello que habéis visto que
giraba todo el rato vale la media 1 gana en auto sample vale y la la mejor es 800 es una locura
claro tampoco es bueno que sea demasiado bueno porque quiere decir que el in sample ha sido
muy malo cuidado con eso que esto es relación a in sample cuando sample cuando es tan bueno
quiere decir que el sample ha ganado mucho pero in sample no ha ganado nada esto que nos dice
que los temas tendenciales al final el sistema lógicamente hay que trabajarlo hay que estudiarlo
pero si bien esto es así en todos en el tendencial es en la máxima expresión de lo que os voy a
decir ahora el vector principal de un tendencial es el mercado mucho más que el sistema por más
bueno que sea el sistema como lo pongas en un activo que no tiene tendencia lo máximo que va
a perder poco aquí ganaba cualquier cosa es igual lo que pusieras de tal manera que volvemos a
mirar estos estos datos vamos a la parte de arriba pero miramos primero sample y aquí vemos que en
el periodo in sample que recordemos en este caso es el hostil vale nuevamente vemos ahí 11 también
el 1 bastante destacable este simple el hostil pero es un hostil más grande es un hostil que
tiene un poco más de margen para trabajar y de paso tiene 3.903 y consigue sacar 140 mil
dólares 160 es decir no lo tiene tan fácil como antes pero a tener mucho margen de trabajo y
tener un periodo muy largo pues se van sucediendo pocas buenas y malas aunque hayan como digo
algunas muy malas no y aquí pues tenemos otra vez 11 1 8 11 son algunos que habíamos visto antes un
2 ahí también un 2 es el mejor expectancy que normalmente nos da aquel que controla mejor el
riesgo por trade vale nos da aquel que mejora con el riesgo por trade y es un 33 2 podemos probarlo
por curiosidad podemos ponerlo por curiosidad volvemos aquí 33 2 esto lo dejo quieto acordaros
el de 3 2 sin salidas y recordar que yo estoy esto para el revés estoy evaluando las medias
simplemente evaluando qué capacidad tiene qué media que qué periodo consigue un equilibrio
mejor entre la porquería o sea la biblia de mercados que tiene de vez en cuando como esto
y aprovechar los buenos mercados porque esto puede parecer muy malo y lo es pero a veces hay muchas
veces que si no lo puedes esquivar es mejor ser rápido porque esto parece muy nefasto pero esto
son muy pocas pérdidas de realidad tomarlos cuando te engancha aquí tal esto realidad es
muy poca pérdida esto está bien para obtención supera potencial está bien porque por eso muchas
veces por eso las adaptativas a veces va muy bien porque tratan de regular eso no y si lo
consiguen casi jode más esto no devolver tanto no devolver tanto pero veis este pedido así lateral
bueno casi va cerrando a coste va muy rápido este ya duele más tendéis no al final claro
para pillar esto hay que hacerlo así fijaros que trae y quién es capaz de aguantar ese tren
si no es con potencial imposible imposible imposible luego hablaremos de filtros para
tratar de minimizar eso pero estamos con hablar no sólo las medias y vamos a que el periodo
bueno para que lo veáis donde claro aquí claro la autoscala parece que sea igual pero
fijaros aquí las grandes recorridos que tiene no también falla tres lógicamente pero los
recorridos son tan largos tan largos tan largos que simplemente es espectacular la cantidad de
beneficio que acumula acumula acumula porque el mercado coge tendencias absolutamente bestiales
y también falla trades pero es lo que os digo esto queda compensado ampliamente por esos mega
trades ahora de esos había menos y ahora ha vuelto alguno ha vuelto alguno veis pero esto
si lo veis aquí un poco más atrás vais a ver que llevábamos mucho tiempo en el oro con muchas
dificultades muchas dificultades con periodos demasiado largos veis aquí demasiado largos esto
ya aquí se complica es porque va vuelve no entre el lateral se hace muy largo veis aquí sí que
va ganando pero no son trades de un gran recorrido y entonces no te da para compensar las pérdidas
de vez en cuando hay uno bueno siempre va a pasar eso pero te da uno bueno que te compensa esta luego
viene otra y acaba siempre que no compensa y por eso te pasas años veis esos laterales te pasas
años puedes pasarte años si no hay filtros con resultados muy malos porque no compensa las
pérdidas pero estén fijados que al final se ha defendido muy bien y también el autor sample con
beneficios bastante buenos seguramente estaremos en profit factor vez inferior incluso antes 109
bastante bastante líneas bastante líneas vale y ésta era para cerrar éste ya no ciego éste era
por curiosidad éste que habíamos visto aquí bueno aquí pues ya digo cuál elegiríamos aquí bueno
no es fácil porque aquí lo recomendable sería conseguir un equilibrio de los dos old datas de
acuerdo por qué porque el old data acordar que al final equilibra en sample y otros sample aquí
hemos visto que teníamos razón y efectivamente el por qué había ido mal el otro teníamos entre
los mejores no teníamos muchos buenos datos de robúndes era por el tipo de mercado pero también
me da una información eso me da una información me da primero porque alguno lo consigue no me da
esa información cuáles lo han conseguido cuáles no han conseguido me da esa información y de los
que lo han conseguido aquí tenemos vez tenemos 100 y evidentemente la que vamos en el old data se
va igualando todo de acuerdo se va igualado todo pero para eso viene bien acuerdo entonces entre
los dos podemos ver es que como os decía 8 11 3 son las medias que claramente dominan con alguno
apareciendo en este caso aquí también 8 3 algún uno pero en general vemos que ese 8 es bastante
bastante repetido también aquí el 11 otra cosa interesante siempre vale es ver los mapas que
esto lo he hecho en multichars y me lo he guardado aquí me lo he guardado aquí porque si no pues
es imposible hacerlo en los mapas aquí tengo el mapa a no todo esto lo vale esto vale es que
hecho hecho ha hecho un cambio aquí me ha acordado no lo explico lo explico porque veis no
vales lo podemos intentar hacer porque no va a tardar tampoco mucho cuando habrá multichar si
nos revienta lo lo probó detrás de hacer vale simplemente o sea el dibujo será este pero la
media no vale porque aquí está la slow contra la fast es un estudio que hemos ido haciendo estudios
luego al final hemos decidido bloquear la slow nos ha parecido mejor práctica hemos decidido bloquear
la slow y entonces hemos cambiado de paradigma hemos el código hecho lo que os digo que la
fase calcula y restando la de la slow entonces ese cambio ya inhabilita esto pero bueno simplemente
para que entendáis el concepto vale luego luego lo intento hacer para que lo veáis el real vale
pero es un poco esto aquí veríamos un poco el mapa y ver un poco por donde por donde respira
ver que no esté aquí no tratar de estar pues bien resguardar vale simplemente como concepto en
definitiva aquí a mí una que me ha gustado mucho porque además el 11 lógicamente al final voy a
buscar alguno eso sí voy a tener en cuenta todos los datos pero le voy a dar importancia a lo actual
de acuerdo le voy a dar la importancia actual entonces yo estoy viendo aquí alguno que gana
bastante bien pero que realmente me ha conseguido mantener un buen autosampe la hora que es el cama
es el 11 es el 11 que viene con cama con a ver a ver 35 11 es un buen candidato hay más
hay más buenos candidatos porque también tenemos aquí este que tiene 143 vale con 19 11 también
esto para esto el mapa nos puede venir bien en esta fase también aquí 34 11 es casi todos los
cama 20 11 para todos estos son los que están dando un buen buen rendimiento los cama en el
otro aquí acordaros que yo cuando tengo esto más 30 la lista la ordeno con suma vale cuando
tengo esto es más 30 no por suma estaba la suma suma perdón si no si rocó rocó rocó con suma vale
así como ya estaba como ya estaba porque porque el roc me ayuda que me parece bien que el roc añada
un punto más a la decisión y cuando al final es sin el autosampe les a principio entonces prefiero
ordenar por suma sin roc que a veces cambia poco pero simplemente no le añado más por este valor
que está es orbitado aquí es lo que os digo cuidado porque no necesariamente es bueno aunque
aunque ya en el old data tiende a equilibrarse pero es a mí este no me gusta este 700 no me gusta
si lo ponemos ahora 7 3 por ejemplo vais a ver que probablemente ha ido muy muy bien en una parte y
mal en la otra era 7 3 era 7 3 7 3 entonces 7 3 esto fijaros las medidas como cambian que
esto es muy interesante por código para este tipo de desarrollo esto ya os digo que es bastante
avanzado como que el código es lo daré y lo veréis pero pero ves es es es una media como habéis
visto antes no es el aquel que habéis visto antes que en general lo normal es si he visto bien que
ganara muchísimo más a lo vez ha ganado muchísimo más en esta en este periodo es aquel que hemos
visto antes creo no cambio aquí sí que tiene este periodo pero se está hundiendo no entonces
pues no acaba de ser una curva que veamos que una media que va siguiendo bien al mercado recuerdo
es lo que os decía parece una cosa más casual y demás no nos inspira a un buen una estabilidad
una buena distribución del beneficio pues no nos gusta entonces esto ya os digo que tampoco nos
interesa nos interesa que haya bastante equilibrio entre una y otra y aquí ya digo podría estar en
éstas o podría podría estar aquí en cualquiera cualquiera cualquiera de éstas para cualquiera de
éstas que equilibrará bien distintos vectores entre éstas que bueno ganan bastante esa de 279
que parece bastante 34 de 4 11 34 11 bastante bien equilibrada bastante bien equilibrada a ver aquí
dónde están aquí también es bueno ver dónde están aquí 34 11 la tengo aquí la veis 34 11 la
tengo aquí 35 12 la tengo aquí un poco más abajo veis 34 11 se coloca un poco mejor en esta
en esta tabla en esta tabla en este periodo así que bueno vamos a poner 34 34 11 vamos a poner 34
no al final de todo el proceso podríamos revisarlo 14 11 que recuerdo el 34 se resta al 46 es decir
estoy haciendo una faz que parece más faz no como que nos parece más coherente no una faz que va
más pegada al precio la lina no se la linda no se mueve nunca bueno se mueve porque cambio el
tipo de media recuerdo cambio el tipo de media pero no se mueve el periodo vale pero fijaros aquí que
tengo una faz que va más pegada pero la lila es una simple por lo tanto es muy lenta y aquí
pues no le da tiempo y como veis pues devuelve mucho dinero al mercado pero ese principio debería
tener una curva algo mejor que la que la anterior a verla es un poco mejor si que tiene sus periodos
malos es lo que os he dicho que fijaros coincide desde agosto del noviembre enero del 15
enero del 15 enero del 20 enero del 15 enero del 20 enero del 15 enero del 20 enero del 15 o
sorpresa es desde aquí desde por aquí a o sorpresa hasta aquí hasta por aquí este periodo superior
este periodo porque aquí veis también es lateral pero es verdad que tiene más rango y ahí pues
seguramente ha conseguido con la media cama adaptarse pero aquí no lo conseguimos de
su periodo gran periodo malo entonces aquí veis un poquito lo que os decía del mercado bien pues
con esto teníamos un poquito dos medidas elegidas vamos a ver si podemos a través de las salidas a
través de las salidas mejorar un poquito un poquito el tema vale cómo podemos hacerlo eso
bueno tenemos antes de probarlo aquí os enseño también unas estos dos nuevamente exels que
tenemos donde he guardado ya los datos estos que estaban bien hechos con las medias ya después
vamos a empezar nuevamente con el más 30 de acuerdo aquí lo que no sé cuál creo que no he
elegido ese que he elegido otro pero es igual es que me da igual me da igual porque casi mejor así
lo independiente uno de otro aquí claro hay menos salidas porque antes hemos hecho en el código
este como ya hicimos el otro día una pequeña adaptación en ciertos en ciertos rangos alberto
está trabajando un poquito las salidas y ver por sí solas a ver dónde podía ir no para ver a para
ver un poco cuál cuál usábamos no para ver qué valor de los periodos de dejado 46 es para no
complicarnos y ahí pues lo que os digo hay un esto porcentaje entonces claro esos valores tenemos
que poner algo medianamente coherente luego a partir de ahí puedes incidir y al final en
otra fase tratar de hacer otra optimización con un mapa y demás pero de momento para hacer una
búsqueda pues hemos buscado unos valores que pudieran estar bien y son estos por entonces
simplemente hemos optimizado las salidas y aquí hemos visto que la 17 la 17 y la 20 parecen
colocar bien la 6 muy curiosa la 6 nos ha sorprendido luego os la enseño porque aparentemente
es muy poco tendencial pero hoy ahí están los resultados con muchísimas operaciones 17 6 20 26
24 entonces un poquito los los que parecen aportar aportar más aquí hay pocas variaciones porque al
final el vector claro es la media acuerdo en este caso luego veremos si podemos filtrar filtrar la
salida podríamos haber puesto aquí un simple stop y dejarlo de esto para ver o pensar que
los sistemas de medias en sí tienen salida de acuerdo entonces no no están imprescindible
en esto paluso porque al final ya veis que sale por lo que sí que a veces sale tarde y mal no
pero pero sale no sale entonces aquí pues miramos a probar por ejemplo en este caso el más 30 y el
menos 30 como ya hemos elegido una media que equilibraba vemos menos diferencias vemos menos
diferencias se parecen muchísimo de hecho son prácticamente iguales si miramos en el in-sample
sí que veremos más diferencias pero si miramos el old data ya no se aprecia casi casi diferencias
acuerdo sample alguna diferencia pero tiene bastante cerrado porque porque en primer lugar
no actúa tanto las salidas ya vais a ver que le cuesta le cuesta elegir una porque le cortan
la tendencia entonces al final normalmente el tendencial le cuesta elegir una salida que
mejore claramente aquí ahora mismo tengo puesta la 17 de acuerdo tengo puesto la 17 que era
efectivamente la mejor in-sample y también la mejor a en el old data para con el más 30 la que
tiene mejor equilibrio entre todos los fitness que usamos o el robot es bueno parece un buen buen
equilibrio y vamos a ver que efectivamente la 17 si no recuerdo mal este p vamos a las salidas
no esto no lo tengo aquí a ver que lo abro un momentito 17 he dicho 17 teníamos de salidas
es el código del otro día esto va a tener un profit atr vale con la que usamos un input que
era el stop y un multiplicador de el stop aquí fijaros que contradice un poco bueno no es que lo
contradiga ya existen que no quería decir que no hubiera que poner que decir que si queremos
un tendencial puro tiene que ser sin tp stop pero no quiere decir que no hay que usarlo a lo mejor
no lo quiero tan puro de acuerdo y me va mejor entiendes que es lo que acaba pasando por qué
porque esta curva que teníamos ahora veremos que la curva pues mejora un poco ves esta periodo
malo ya no está malo ya no está malo ahora la curva ya ha mejorado bastante sólo poniéndole
esta salida de acuerdo sigue teniendo un profit factor que no es muy elevado pero fijaros aquí
ya tenemos 1 17 con 1 21 y 1 13 y con comisiones está bastante razonable esto es un sistema
probablemente operable así no hemos filtrado todavía no hemos aplicado ningún filtro ningún
filtro vale simplemente cruce de medias con salidas y stop esto que a veces salta como veis que
valores tiene bueno sólo habíamos hecho un estudio antes puede hacer también vamos a tratar
de hacer este par de estudios que hemos dicho si nos deja lo intentaremos quitaré la cámara
no sé quitaré de compartir la pantalla que me lo sugería antes creo aureli para ver si es eso
aún un problema con el controlador de la tarjeta gráfica no sé aquí era la salida 17 acordaros
que cada uno tenía un ímpus veces 5 a terres y el profit es 2 y medio más vale quiere decir
que es 12 12 no 5 por 2 y medio 12 y medio claro 12 y medio 5 a terres de esto 12 y medio de tp
por eso que os decía hombre no hay que poner tp bueno hombre le puesto 12 a terres de tp es decir
le puesto un tp que lógicamente algunas veces va a dejar a dejar correr esto aquí parece una
sobreutilización pero acordaros que estamos con 5.000 trade es que hay momentos que sale antes
hay momentos y muchos no sale realmente no sale tantas veces pero al final cuando pones un tp
miramos aquí es aquí deja perder mucho tramo de tendencia pero hubiera pillado más bueno sólo
hubiera pillado más con un tp más alto pero no lo hubiera pillado sino porque ves que provoca
una vuelta espectacular y te la pierdes al final vendemos entonces al final cuando haces estos
tps que buscas una dinámica de volatilidad que normalmente sabes que el mercado a través de
ese expansión recordar el mercado siempre expande contrae expande contrae el mercado ya agota ya no
hay fuerza para seguir como veis casi siempre es así van a haber excepciones 100% sobre todo
en este primer tramo donde habíamos visto que subía tanto para haber excepciones pero fijaros
que con caídas muy fuertes y subidas a veces no hacen y tp pero a veces que sí que pilla está
casi el máximo porque porque no es que sea un ejercicio sobre optimización es que al final del
mercado tiene esa dinámica de expansión aquí fíjate que no hace tp y de y devuelve veis y no
le dan y para el esto porque porque no estrella también ahí estaba el tren y también pero
considera que le va a peor el tren hay veces que hace tp es fantástico es que devuelve todo esto
todo es un coste de oportunidad ventaja desventaja es aquí fijaros que su vida pero no le da para
hacer el tp hubiera tenido un tp más cercano pues hubiera cerrado aquí pero a cambio pues no hubiera
hecho esos grandes trades entonces hay que en un tendencial sólo tiene sentido de esta manera con
tp es muy locos esto no es un tp loco pero se le acerca es un tp medio loco pero fijaros la
cantidad de bienes que tiene fuertes donde no hace tp sólo lo hacen movimientos de mucha expansión y
algunas veces ves aquí hubiera podido sacar más pero fijaros que casi siempre después vuelve
vertical porque el mercado es así es aquí fijaros todo lo que pierde de ganancia aquí
sí que realmente hubiera ganado mucho más pero a cambio otros no hubiera hecho tp y lo
verá de vuelta entonces es lo que es lo que os digo y hay esto se lo habéis ido viendo también
esto es esta salida parece un buen equilibrio entre stop y tp y convierte la curva en bastante más
llevadera ajustado por volatilidad también el porcentaje bruto no iba mal vamos a la parte
inicial del gráfico vamos a la parte inicial del gráfico donde ahí veremos enganchadas fuertes
aquí algunas mira algún stop aquí aquí también vamos aquí que enganchada para empezar aquí
rápidamente ya empieza y ves aquí donde donde hay muchos tramos de tendencia limpios aquí mira
nos saca y en falso es te saca por poco de esto y se pierde la caída no se pierde la caída porque
no hay un cruce este con el cruce de con el hecho de no de no ir por cruce hubiera vuelto
a entrar seguramente pero esto esto cambia mucho el sistema pero esto os quiero decir esto esto
de señal cruce tru señal cruce false a ver qué pasa no pasa que aquí sólo tiene sentido en el
don chanel porque realmente va a vender directo es para vender directo no tiene sentido no tiene
sentido el stop así ni el tp ni nada porque va a vender directo si se siguen dando las condiciones
a vender directo o sea así este setup de tal sólo tiene sentido con don chan no va a ir mal
tampoco pero pero va a ir peor peor porque ya digo que sólo tendría sentido con el don chan si porque
necesite algo más al salir porque si no sale y vuelve a entrar porque en ese en ese caso siempre
que la media esté cortada él vende o compra entonces se sale y al siguiente verá volver a entrar
habría que controlar eso para que tuviera sentido ya digo habría que activar el don chan esto casi
alberto se podía haber resumido en una única variable porque es absurdo false con false entonces
con una ya con una ya está porque el tru no sé lo sé sí sí pero por eso que sólo con una ya estaba
porque realmente en false es absurdo en false es absurdo entonces en tru bueno aquí en tru sí
que tiene sentido tru false o tru tru no sé si tru tru sí tru tru tampoco por no pero desesperar al
don chan sólo en una no lo creo que no así sí que tiene sentido lo que pasa que evidentemente
en momentos pues que tarda mucho habría que ver el don chan así como queda esto sería con el
filtro don chan activado pero no está no está mirado nada del filtro es decir seguramente no
tiene ningún tipo de sentido como está puesto ahora pero así sería con un filtro don chan como
habéis entrado mucho menos mejora mejora en sobremanera la curva es otra curva es otro
sistema pero simplemente para que lo veáis vale así ya es otro sistema opera menos aunque tiene
1400 trades pero ya hemos mejorado mucho los ratios este fijaros si es robusto a la media y
la salida sí con esta dinámica que metiendo los don chan que ni lo hemos mirado es decir
este don chan yo lo activado ahora a no activado con el false ahí no a no porque ese es el otro
perdón perdón lo quito lo quito que va a liar esto que está el otro metido aún este lo quito que
ya no se está usando lo quito he borrado la intradía uno que no que los saben of pero en
el performance report sale alberto este simplemente ahora activado el don chan vale para que lo veáis
activado el don chan pero dejado un parámetro que nos estaba puesto antes 41 porque me de 46 que
lo que usábamos antes y aquí hay un par de filtros que en un largo está cero y cero tres pero está
totalmente casual de verdad o sea no no tiene no se ha mirado nada de esto esto y ya sólo esto de
hecho para nuestra opinión lo mejor no tocarlo sería en 46 o sea este habría que dejarlo no
este no este 46 el periodo y el canal que en una sesión también abierto es demasiado duro no es
demasiado así yo creo haber así es demasiado duro es entrará muchísimo si operará muy poco así
seguramente se podría plantear así pero ahora analizar las medias de nuevo entendéis decir
bloquear el don chan como está ahora en 46 decirle bueno tienes que superar los máximos de una
sesión de 46 velas entre el ligue cuidado que equivale a una sesión de duración pero
analizo las medias para ese condicionante porque si no el don chan es muy restrictivo
entonces opera muy poco seguramente va a ganar es muy bien aún así tiene 700 straight pero es
muy restrictivo tenemos una curva mucho más estable así estoy entrando prácticamente por
don chan pero es verdad que las medias me dan un plus es medias más don chan de acuerdo fijarnos
esta curva se podría perfectamente trabajar no lo hemos trabajado porque lo he dejado para el
final como filtro pero puede puede implementarse en este caso como considerarse señal básica de
entrada bloquearlo ahora y trabajar las medias con este don chan seguramente que haga unas medias más
rápidas pero obligar en la media de 46 y el canal de 46 es muy restrictivo pero es válido
o sea restrictivo es válido y me atrevería a decir contada porencia del mundo que probablemente
es robusto probablemente es robusto porque es un activo muy tendencial y es muy lógico ya veis
que que que los ratios son buenos cada menos que el otro porque es menos tendencial es tendencial
pero es menos tendencial pero fijaros que curva está en máximos prácticamente ahora ahora acaba
de ser el sede máximos porque ha fallado estos dos aquí parecía que rompía se ha fallado aquí
parecía que rompía ha fallado y se ha salido por estos y ahora vamos a esperar siguiente rotura pero
evidentemente es un es un sistema que de esta manera pues da bastante bastante recurrido o sea
es un condicionante tan grande que habría que replantear las medias y incluso las salidas pero
hacerlo de manera independiente es buena práctica y ya veis que cuando las reglas son sólidas el
sistema aguanta porque esta es la gracia la independencia de las reglas si son buenas a
mejor no son las mejores pero deben aguantar el tipo al cambiar bien volvemos a donde estábamos
porque eso simplemente quería mostraros un momento el don chan el hecho de cruce no cruce
y ya lo hemos hecho los un caso si tenemos tiempo volvemos vale dejamos el don chan en
formes y nos quedamos con nuestras medias que operan mucho más también ganan más pero
lógicamente la curva no están estables más tendencial y también devuelve más dinero a veces
y opera mucho más aunque recuerda que las condiciones están implementadas vale para
que se pueda comparar todo así que ya la curva no es tan estable como está pero no está nada mal
para un tendencial no está nada mal y fijaros que gana bastante más 344 antes creo que estábamos
en ciento y pico en un contrato que he cuidado en el gesto monetario importante pero 121 17
peor profit factor pero muchísimas más operaciones y veis 36 por ciento a pesar de tener tp sus
ratios son de muy tendencial porque es un tp que en la mayoría de las veces no salta y cuando
salta en una aplastante veces el mercado revierte o sea el mercado es lo que os digo es un es un
tp casi loco no no no es loco porque salta bastante pero es casi loco es casi loco realmente las
subidas son de un tramo muy importante es aquí fijaros que este trade compra en 2354 y cierra
en 2004 28 mil tres son 75 puntos en 7.500 no alberto hay 7.000 son 75 mil no no me he ido me he ido
7.500 7.500 entonces bien así como está es un sistema que entra en operable en operable es un
tendencial puro y tal ahora qué podríamos hacer con él podríamos tratar de filtrar aquí simplemente
hemos hecho un análisis yo lo que voy a hacer de las salidas con un primer análisis de medias
de acuerdo primero uno y luego otro vale de momento no he analizado filtros bueno es una pequeña
prueba ahora con el con el don chan que no lo había hecho o sea le ha hecho a ciegas y habéis
visto que iba iba bien iba bien vale entonces ahora lo que vamos a hacer es intentar abrir
multichars vale para lo que voy a quitar la cámara como bien me he sugerido aquí creo que
aureli voy a dejar de compartir la pantalla un momento no sé si eso eso va a hacer algo pero
por si acaso vamos a intentar vamos a intentar a ver si eso aumenta las probabilidades de éxito
vamos porcemos los dedos está toda la mañana todo el día vaya ayer también o sea todo el día de
ayer y hoy he estado trabajando con este con este con este mix con los dos abiertos incluso
había un momento que optimizado con los dos a la vez con los dos a la vez venga aguanta venga
aguanta y aguanta a ver si aureli va a tener razón y resulta que es la cámara no ya ya a
veces espera me han apretado dos veces seguidas si no no yo creo que no es eso que es casual pero
vaya por si acaso por si acaso esto los otros las de las de salidas
pues sí que gracias a ver este de la este que tengo de la parece que abre bien ahora
ahora vuelvo a darle que parece que sí que está backfilling está backfilling venga voy a compartir
voy a compartir vamos con todo la cámara da igual total ya para lo que hay que ver para lo que hay
que ver nos va a faltar pues ahí está es al buro de multichars con el mismo el mismo sistema el
mismo sistema a ver si lo tengo esto con qué impulso tengo tendencia 2 35 bueno antes he puesto
34 por mantenerlo esto no actúa no actúa no actúa no actúa esto no actúa no actúa nada y
y lo de la de x y tal que ahora vamos a ver vamos a ver ahora antes voy a hacerlo de las
medias vale voy a hacerlo de las medias que creo que lo voy a poner y mientras hablo y tal no va
no va a tardar mucho para que veáis el mapa a ver si me lo deja hacer vale eso en principio es
bastante sencillo porque simplemente vamos a salidas no salidas no tocó nada aquí tendencia
es el slow fijo vale este lo optimizo desde 1 a 45 y está la media era de 119 alerto 119 verdad vale
perfecto esto tengo tengo tengo metido aquí el soltino no no está metido no a mí no me da
no lo tengo no es activado joder pues igual a lo por el profil de esa vale lo por el profil
venga venga la verdad que en este mi pc también el procesador es muy eficiente la verdad y lo
normal es que no se corta ni nada si alguien oye que se corta la voz o algo que me avise que le
quito cores para para mejorar la mejorar el rendimiento de la cámara pero vaya en principio
yo creo que va a aguantar y no va a tardar demasiado no va a tardar demasiado pronostica
5 que lo puede lo puede mejorar esta procesadora del 100 por 100 88 para multichars ahí os lo dejo
que lo veáis hay cortes puedo quitar cores pero entonces menos de cuatro no hace nada le voy a
quitar cuatro y así aunque tarde un minuto dos más nos aseguramos que no nos revienta el vídeo
a ver si no nos graba bien el vídeo y la voy a aprovechar para mocar un momentito
venga ahí va tres minutos y bajando si puede aprovechar para hacer la pausa sí sí aprovechar
para hacer para hacer la pausa aprovechar para hacer la pausa y yo no la no la bueno
o sea no la ponen sentido cuando acabe sigo pero saca de un control marca tres minutos
pero si si marcar marcar pausa para un momento la grabación y hacemos una pausita aprovechando
esto pero ya digo son tres minutitos de pausa bien ya estamos de vuelta otra vez acaba la
optimización a ver que me están dando la alineación directo de cuidado me están dando la alineación
en directo alberto como es merengón no me la no me la da a ver un momentito primero lo importante
en sorpresas en sorpresas en sorpresas para ahí estamos a ver este es el ese es el mapa de la
variable fast y la variable media aquí el mapa en sí no no vais a ver una progresión porque claro
la el tipo de media no no no es una variable que tenga una progresión de sí no hay ninguna
relación entre 1 el 2 el 3 el 4 en el número de medias y lo más interesante de ver aquí si
os fijáis es que una vez elegida la media el periodo no es tampoco súper crítico hay mucha
estabilidad un poco lo la una de las pocas cosas que podemos que podemos ver que a lo largo de
las medias hay hay bastante estabilidad aquí incluso a veces sí que viene bien a mejor coger
el de 2 vale coger el de 2 y eliminar que hayan dos porque no hemos cargado el sortino ahora
meter solo net profit y a quien fixe tipo bloquear por ejemplo la que la que hemos usado que no me
acuerdo si era la cual era la 3 era la no la la 8 era no ahora me acuerdo jodete tú la 11 la 11
era la 11 la 11 venga mira entonces lo que hace aquí la 11 ves y ves un poco el mapa en 2 para
la 11 de acuerdo es como evoluciona la faz para la 11 entonces aquí sí que se ve un poco mejor sus
zonas de trabajo no bueno evidentemente en toda la en toda la zona tiene retorno positivo que eso
es importante pero sí que es verdad que tiene unos picos aquí que son un poquito bruscos es verdad
que son un poquito bruscos aunque aquí sí que podemos dar cierta estabilidad en toda esta
zona pues sí que decae pero pero se sigue manteniendo los ritmos que no están mal pero
sí que la verdad que sería mejor un poco más amplia sería mejor un poco más amplia y esto lo
podemos hacer para todas de acuerdo podemos mirar lo mejor si estábamos entre varias no decíamos
antes me acuerdo por ejemplo también la 3 no vamos a ver hoy el siglo que la 3 a ver qué tal
lo como como de estable es la 3 pero parece más estable la 3 no parece más estable la 3 veis un
poco la idea no podemos un poco jugar con esto y ver un poco la 1 incluso no la 1 pero la simple
con simple simple con simple es muy estable también no al final en caso de duda quedarnos con la simple
pero también no veíamos que nos gustaba me acuerdo antes que había exponencial con cama no recuerdo
cuál era no simple con cama era no siempre con cama si cuál era la era la 11 era la 11 era la que
estábamos mirando ahora antes no se ha salido recuerdo la 3 a la 8 que era exponencial con
normal la 8 la 8 también la 8 la 8 muy estable está en esta casa que es la mejor en esta casa
que es la mejor en estabilidad fijáis en esto da un margen de maniobra absolutamente gigantesco
esto te colocas aquí y estás ahí en el absoluto paraíso viendo el mapa la verdad que esta parece
la mejor habría que ver a ver si podemos con esta media conseguir mediante las salidas entendéis
un poco los filtros y tal que este tenga un rendimiento como el que tenemos ahora porque
es mejor es mejor es el que parece más estable de acuerdo porque si hemos tenido el 11 que nos da
mejores resultados pero si ahora las otras no nos acaba de gustar esto esto cama con simple muy
bien muy bien valores hay muy todo pero de grada fácil poco estable cuidado esto es probable es
más fácil que de grabe en el futuro entendéis en cambio fijaros no con la 1 con lo más sencillo
siempre es lo que ocurre pero para eso son los datos es la 1 la simple muy estable la 2 exponencial
con exponencial también súper estable pero no tanto con simple con exponencial la 3 cama con
cama a ver bueno ya ves las dos cama sigue siendo más volátil lo veis sigue siendo más volátil y
además de grada mucho negativo y todo es a estar acaba con cámara no funciona cámara tiene que ir
con algo pero ahí ya metemos 8 y dices o hostia cuidado cuidado con la 8 que está en el 1 fijaros
dices hostia la 1 muy bien la 8 a ver es que no hay y acordaros que salía y ahora mismo me
quedaría con la 8 aquí chicos y chicas que no me acuerdo ser chicas normalmente hay pocas chicas
no sé por qué la verdad es una lástima pero pero así es así se van apuntando más salidas
medias aquí era esto me parece que el 8 estaba bien también veis tenemos 8 ahí fijaros muy bien
el 8 nos pasamos al 8 en familia nos pasamos al 8 claramente nos pasamos al 8 claramente para
estos son los mapas veis nos pasamos al 8 claramente porque aquí en menos 30 fijaros que
arrasa muy bien casi todos es el que más sale de calle vale pero aquí también en el que en el
que es más 30 también o sea en el menos 30 es el que sale mejor pero es que en el más 30 es el
mismo que no me había dado cuenta antes poco jaimito por mi parte porque fijaros que es el
mismo y no tiene por qué porque el orden cambia y a ver en el sample en el sample también tenemos
a 8 aquí y aquí también tenemos 8 muy bien 8 muy bien 8 sí sí sí sí muy claro muy claro 8 aquí
ahora claro el tema es que este 48 sí que ahora recientemente nos ha parecido degradar pero teniendo
en cuenta esto que estamos viendo aún así tendría sentido valorar si lo asumimos si lo
asumimos porque sabemos que el mercado ha ido mal que no le ha ido suyo y podemos asumirlo
podemos también valorar otro también hay que ver las salidas cómo le afectan porque ahora este
estudio antes lo hemos hecho con la otra media ahora habría que hacer el estudio de salidas
vamos a pasarlo eso sí que es un momento ya con eso lo acabaremos vale ese es ahora el 48 pero
con las salidas que ya hemos elegido 1 14 19 y 10 para ver lo que decía ahora vale ha costado más
pero habría que ver habría que hacer un juego de salidas por lo mejor en vez de esta tan rápida es
que está muy muy está muy pegada y a lo mejor buscar otro otro 8 no a lo mejor buscar otro 8
que nos haya dado un mejor resultado aquí por ejemplo este da 75 aquí 22 8 vale podemos marcarlo
aquí en marrón no sé si no porque no se ve lila este 22 8 este 18 vale no este ya no este de grada
este es parecido al anterior aquí tenemos otros 76 23 8 vale cuesta con los 8 aquí conseguir buenos
buenos retornos bueno habría que ver si con este 22 y 23 8 podemos ver podemos ver que vaya que vaya
un poco mejor en y ver un poco jugando con las salidas vale pero es perfectamente hecho este
periodo lo ha clavado bastante clavado bastante parece es lo que os digo al final van a sufrir
todos en temas buscar qué equilibrio cómo sufre dónde pero donde no hay tendencia nuevamente van
a sufrir puede que yo aquí siempre me encargaría por la robustez por lo tanto elegiría de esta
zona elegiría un tipo 8 y ahora viendo esto el mapa podríamos incidir en ello bloquear el 8
ver a ver la media trabajarla ver a ver las salidas pero ya bloqueando el 8 oye el 8 me
ha gustado mucho veo que hay mucha mucha robustez aquí me quedo con ella me quedo con ella vale
porque además fijaros que es que me da igual desde el 1 desde el 1 hasta el 30 puedo elegirla
en faz me da igual me da igual sabes que tengo una una curva muy estable hasta que no llega muy
arriba no degrada mucho porque se acerca que es casi igual no entonces pierde totalmente rendimiento
pero pero realmente se mantiene muy bien muy bien en esta primera zona de muy muy lenta acordaros
que resta de la de la lenta por lo tanto esto es media lenta y esto es media rápida media más
rápida entonces a ver en esta que habíamos visto 22 22 o 23 o 22 o 23 vamos a probar 22 22 8
ya los como la media hora va a quedar más cerca del precio porque resta del es lobo acordaros
es ahí 22 8 veis ahora que es más rápida aquí ya por ejemplo ves ya pues ya no ya no ha hecho
un tray tan bueno pero ha seguido haciendo este tp aquí no bien este esto es interesante ahora
que podemos hacer aquí mira vamos a hacer vamos a hacer lo mismo que hemos hecho aquí ahora con
las salidas dejamos 22 8 dejamos 22 8 true falls y está todo lo demás no juega y yo solo estoy
prácticamente estoy optimizando sólo una media y he analizado los distintos tipos de media pero
prácticamente estoy utilizando una media y ahora luego un poco las salidas vale decir realmente
no he optimizado mucho vale no he hecho una optimización muy intensiva de muy
máxima y tengo 5000 que podría hasta darle un poco más pero estoy estoy de momento sin
sin forzar las cosas entonces yo ahora aquí lo que no sé si esto lo tengo bien puesto pero vamos
a probarlo vamos a probarlo así directamente esto ya está aquí lo voy a optimizar y esto
era salidas aquí no es de 0 a 32 o 31 31 o 32 32 0 32 vale no optimizo nada más es
porque no no lo he metido y vamos con ello esos son 33 o sí que va a durar pues nada
minutos minutos no minuto nada y eso que le dejo los 16 coles por tranquilidad a
dar segundos esto vale y aquí pues podemos ver ahora un poco el mapa en 2d porque sólo hay
una variable bueno vemos aquí no tiene mucho sentido es simplemente es por ver a ver cómo
como van ordenamos por un profit vemos que la 26 a 16 y la 5 bueno aquí sí que iría bien ahora
aplicarlo vamos a cerrar aquí a no esperate vamos a abrir otra vez el informe de optimización y
les voy a las voy a ir aplicando vale simplemente las que ganan más por verlas vale esta era la
número 26 salida 26 que luego habría que hacer otro ajuste porque al final los inputs que hemos
elegido no son los óptimos simplemente es por tener una pequeña referencia vamos a ver a 26
la 26 es un profit porcentual con breakeven curioso profit porcentual con breakeven esta es
nuestra curva global y la vemos en el largo y la vemos en el corto pero bueno ambas tienen
una pendiente razonable para un tendencial 258 tenemos un profit factor de 116 122 109 quizá el
corto un poquito cojo pero bueno pero al final es un activo que ha subido mucho es complicado no
está mal no no no está mal no está mal pero bueno todavía yo creo que tiene camino de mejora vía
vía la salida dejarla más fina y vía también la filtro de acuerdo aquí se puede tratar de filtrar
tenemos tres caminos de acordar dan chan a de x y a terro 16 bien este es este es uno el otro
que le daba era a ver distintas salidas tengo aquí tenemos esta también que era la número 16 número
16 a ver qué era esto porcentual y profit porcentual bueno esto ya es más con un multiplicador
sabe usa un poco más vamos a ver cómo queda performance report o veis ahí los cps vamos a
poner el tiempo real no porque no es el otro hemos cargado lo cargado hasta el viernes hoy
que así nos meterá también un poco lo actual ahí hay poco madera a ver que ya voy a cerrar esto
aquí el camino de los filtros no lo hemos no lo hemos trabajado mucho los que más probada de
x y a terreno nos han aportado realmente en los tendenciales lo que más aporta de acuerdo lo que
más aporta en un tendencial y breakout es no operar más que operar es no operar cuando hay
expansiones muy fuertes de gratidad esto es lo que suele aportar más valor esto hay varias
maneras de identificarlo puede ser con aterre puede ser con pautas de precio pero quedaros con esta
idea de acuerdo a más filtrarlo no operar cuando cuando cuando ha habido mucha expansión porque ya
cuando había expansión normalmente es tarde para entrar entonces se que habrá veces que sí pero de
media normalmente te ahorras más disgustos cuando ya se ha producido una expansión espérate es decir
por ejemplo este corto probablemente con un filtro de expansión no lo hace porque tras
expansión normalmente viene reversión veis esta es la idea este de verdad que es un ejemplo muy
bueno es tras una expansión así normalmente bien esto y a veces hasta más entendéis esto es lo que
hay detrás de la de esta lógica de acuerdo entonces tras expansión que veis aquí que ha
habido abajo es su vida volatilidad entonces normalmente aunque me dice la verdad que lo
estoy mirando no no parece aportar mucho normalmente tras su vida volatilidad a veces es como lo
identificas con puede ser con una veras normalizada que esté subiendo además hay que verlo hay que
hay que trabajarlo un poco pero normalmente las expansiones de volatilidad que es volatilidad más
de cierto nivel y subiendo normalmente esto esto suele filtrar su filtrar bien y habrá
excepciones habrá excepciones siempre pero ya digo es más no operar en esos momentos que el hecho
de operar en determinados momentos vale habéis más más filtra más el no sabéis el que el sí
entendéis decir en este caso no vale y aquí tenemos como quedaba este performance pero bastante
similar al anterior ahí se ve la curva pues para una curva típica de un tendencial está está
bastante bien es bastante estable en todos los períodos aquí tenemos el largo que tenemos el
corto que tiene ha ido bien lógicamente ahora está pegado un tiro muy fuerte ya ha sufrido pero
en términos generales pues no lo está haciendo mal tenemos un salva normalizado 78 un 0 45 de
sortino que si lo anualizamos 0 45 por raíz de 12 nos da un 1 55 si lo dividimos por raíz de 2
acordaros para compararlo con sortino lo vimos en la práctica nos da 1 10 que es bastante más que
0 78 quiere decir que tenemos mucha más volatilidad buena que mala siempre es bueno
entonces bien la verdad que así así me parece a mí un sistema que ya es es es bueno para un
tendencial del loro pero tenemos camino de mejor había había filtros ya hemos visto en una cosa
rápida que por filtros de doncha mejorábamos pero nos quedaría valorar el filtro de atr lo
tenemos aquí en el código pero en la versión que hemos probado no ha aportado nivel atr mayor
que cero de tal y lo de igual a mayor que atr le tienes que pedir no mayor o no tiene que ser
menor para pegar a no claro claro no o sea que sea true a ver cabros y así opera cuando sea alta
la volatilidad alberto es al revés sería esto no menor si ya claro no filtro atr claro que lo
estaba negado hay que negarlo y debería ahí puede ser que aporte vamos a ver ahí puede ser que
aporte vamos a probarlo rápido puede ser que igual creciente lo que decía alberto puede ser
creciente aquí aquí le ponemos claro me lo invento no le pongo la optimización pequeñita rápida
no cien no puedo que no puedo salida 16 será la que había dejado supongo que si no es la que
es la que he marcado claro filtro atr no sé no perdón esto lo dejo en 46 vale no merece lo
uno no tiene que ser 0 10 al menos 0 pero 15 quizás 0 10 0 20 va a ser mucho en tío no
no mire el indicador abajo sin 0 20 la media histórica 0 16 tiene razón limitada no la
media histórica es igual acuérdate pero no aporta creer así como están aporta es que
no está actuando aquí es que no está actuando cuando actúa se degrada no está mal configurado
está mal configurado está mal yo creo que se ha confiado así 240 varía muy poco cuando varía
se degrada mucho no no es que esto tiene a ver espérate a espérate a perfecto se me parece que
lo he tocado en el easy language alberto lo que he hecho es evitarlo en easy language perfecto muy
bien lo he hecho lo he hecho muy bien lo he hecho muy bien es una jambitada pero efectivamente como
veis antes no iba ahora ahora voy a cambiar para que vaya venga vamos seguimos limitada ha sido ha
sido épica esta sido épica esta sido épica a ver venga calma aquí no está el filtro que tengo
aquí los que es para es que esto no es todo que no me deje identar tío me mata tío de verdad más
arriba así aquí joder y aquí foros y ahora ya niego y hasta a ver si ahora aporta alguno y si
voy a hacer la misma vamos espérate que voy a poner esto 41 por verlo sabes 46 no perdón aún
aún da valores más bajos alberto claro no da valores mucho más altos claro claro así termina
mucho la volatilidad de fondo no no sé me parece que lo dejo en 14 me parece que lo dejo en 14 no
me no me convence lo veo demasiado rígido para ser un filtro así venga bueno sigue siendo un churro
patatero no no está bien hay que pensarlo bien es que pensarlo bien en el gráfico porque no
no estamos no estamos sentiéndolo bien sería más sentido antes que ahora sería más sentido antes
que ahora por la idea es lo que la idea es la que la cosa he dicho es eso es claro la cosa es
cómo lo lo consigas plasmar pero pero la la clave la clave es la que os digo la clave es la que os
digo cuando ya ha habido una expansión de volatilidad es que el mercado ya ha desarrollado
su movimiento entonces esa es la idea momento bueno de un breakout o de un tendencial es más
cuando hay menos volatilidad pero ya digo para un breakout puede valer los dos lados para un
tendencial vale más la contraria es decir por eso intentaba negarlo pero creo que lo
hecho bien o que pensarlo con calma para traducir esta idea que os digo recuerdo que es no entrar
cuando ya ha habido expansión es decir cuando la volatilidad salta no entra ese es un poco el
el concepto vale y ya está hasta aquí el sistema tendencial queda pendiente de hoy ya sé que tengo
pendiente de subir los otros de las salidas pero quiero complementarlo con algunas entradas vale
para que tengáis varias entradas ya en ese código sea un código para que probáis cosas de manera
muy práctica queda enviaros ese enviaros este por supuesto y enviaros lo que hemos dicho hoy
de la strategy concepts que esto sí que seguro que lo que queda de semana os lo subo en el disco
de acuerdo así que nada más si no hay más preguntas por hoy lo vamos a dejar aquí muy
interesante creo que es muy interesante hoy la parte que habéis visto que con un simple cruce de
medias trabajando un poquito se puede sacar algo bastante útil así ya es útil muy útil diría yo
y esto mismo va en el petróleo por ejemplo pero perfectamente o sea es posible es posible que
cambiado así directo vamos que no no me va a cargar me va a reventar me va a reventar pero
es posible que así mismo vaya en el petróleo no óptimo pero vaya y ya os digo son activos que
este tipo de sistemas sencillos sentenciales les van bien como habéis visto el paráboli que
también va muy bien estos dos sistemas en el oro pueden funcionar perfectamente y queda pendiente
aplicar algún filtro que funcione que se puede hacer se puede hacer para evitar algunas entradas
en momentos de poca eficiencia de acuerdo así que pongo la carátula que siempre para despedir nos
queda mejor y doy por acabada la clase de hoy hasta pronto chao